PLAN RETIREMENT WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON RESPONSE
TO THE COPA NINETY NUMBERS SEEM
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC CLOUDS
LEADERS AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN HERE. TO SOCIAL DOESN'T SEEM
AN FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHEERS ME
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. TODAY EACH SIDE WILL
BE PERMITTED TO EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHEER- IN THAT TIME ACTUALLY
WILL BE TWO MINUTES FOR LEAD
WITNESSES. OF FOR EACH WITNESS-
AND THERE'S NO RESERVING TIME
FOR OTHER WITNESSES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THOSE WHO ARE CALLING IN. FOR
THESE WITNESSES THERE WILL BE A
LIMIT OF TEN MINUTES FOR
SUPPORT. AND TEN MINUTES FOR
OPPOSITION THOSE ARE TOTAL
TIMES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITHIN MINIMUM IS THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN WE HOPE THAT WE
ARE HAVING SOME TECHNOLOGICAL
PROBLEMS TODAY- AND- BECAUSE OF
THAT I WILL REPEAT THIS NUMBER-
DURING THE COURSE OF THE
MEETING. THAT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AGAIN TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT PHONE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX.
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FIVE ZERO ZERO SIX
THREE ZERO EIGHT. IF YOU'RE
WRITING THAT DOWN IT'S FIVE
ZERO ZERO SIX THREE ZERO EIGHT.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECOM CONSISTENT THE
SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE REFER TO
THE SENATE. FOR THE LABOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE ZERO FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION PROCESS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. OF THIS OFTENTIMES CAN
BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER.
AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON
MUTE IN IN YOU'RE NOW READY TO
TRUST THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING.
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS MUTED. ALL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENT TH SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE A BILLS. WE HAVE ONE
BUILT ON CONSENT SB SIX FORTY
FOUR- WHICH IS SENATOR LEAVE
HIS BILL- BUT BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS OR
THE CONSENT. ITEM BUT SYSTEM
WAS A QUORUM. I'M SUPER THE
CONSULTANT LOW ASK YOU TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
CORTEZ A YEAR. SENATOR JOE BOOK
HERE SENATOR DORADO. SENATOR
LAYERED. SENATOR NEWMAN HERE.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM- I THINK
WE WILL WAIT TO SEE IF WE CAN
GET THEM A FULL COMPLEMENT HERE
BEFORE WE TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH MEANS WILL MOVE
TO ITEM ONE ON THE AGENDA WHICH
HAPPENS TO BE SB THREE THIRTY
FIVE WHICH IS MY BILL-
THEREFORE I'M GOING TO
IMMEDIATELY. TRANSFER THE GAVEL
OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR
MEDAVOY'S SURE ALTOGETHER WON'T
COME OVER TO YOU. TO COME WITH
COMMITTEE RULES WHICH SAY THAT
THE CHAIR- WILL NOT PRESIDE
OVER THE PRESENTATION. OF HIS
OR HER OWN BILL. WELCOME
SENATOR CORTESE YOU MAY NOW
PRESENTER BILL SB THREE THREE
FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MINIATURE. TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB THREE THIRTY FIVE OF
WHICH I BELIEVE IS COMMONSENSE
MEASURE THAT WOULD SEEK TO
REDUCE UNREASONABLE DELAYS ON
WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS
UNDER EXISTING LAW TIMELINES.
MANY EMPLOYERS WAIT UNTIL THE
TAIL END OF THE NIGHT IS
CURRENTLY ALLOWED THEM TO DENY
WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS
CAUSING SERIOUS IMPACTS TO
EMPLOYEES PHYSICAL MENTAL WELL
BEING AND DOING THEM EVEN
FURTHER FROM COMPREHENSIVE
TREATMENT AND EVENTUAL RETURN
TO WORK. SB THREE THIRTY FIVE
WOULD REDUE THE TIME THAT AN
EMPLOYER HAS TO DENY OR ACCEPT
LIABILITY FOR A WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIM FROM NINETY
DAYS TO FORTY FIVE DAYS. FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY OF VOICES WOULD
BE REDUCED EVEN FURTHER TO
THIRTY DAYS. WELL THERE'S A
BACK INJURY CAUSING SEVERE PAIN
OR CANCER THAT NEEDS URGENT
TREATMENT BEFORE CAN SPREAD
QUICKLY TO THE CATION OF AN
INJURY CLAIM SHOULD BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT RESPONSE FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY EMPLOYEE WHO'S BEEN
INJURED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
ADDITIONALLY SB THREE THIRTY
FIVE WOULD IMPOSE A 10%
INCREASE ON THE AMOUNT DUE FOR
ANY PAYMENT OF COMPENSATION IS
FOUND TO BE UNREASONABLY
DELAYED OR REFUSED. OPPONENTS
OF THIS LEGISLATION WILL SAY
THAT IT'S AN UNDULY HARSH
PUNISHMENT I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THIS PROVISION IS TARGETED
TOWARDS. UNREASONABLE DELAYS
AND REFUSALS WHICH ARE TOOLS OF
BAD ACTOR IMPORTERS. FINALLY SB
THREE THIRTY FIVE WOULD
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MEDICAL
TREATMENT AN EMPLOYER MUST
IMMEDIATELY COVER. FROM
1-000-021-7000 DOLLARS. THIS IS
A REASONABLE INCREASE THAT
INTENDS TO PRESERVE THE VALUE
OF THESE BENEFITS BY KNOWLEDGE
IN THE INCREASES IN THE COST OF
LIVING. SINCE THE INCEPTION OF
THE ORIGINAL DOLLAR AMOUNT.
HERE WITH US TO TESTIFY OVER
THE PHONE HIS CHRISTY PALMER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
THANK YOU MENTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE
FIVE- AND WE DO HAVE LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS CHRISTY BALMA
SHE ON THE LINE. BOTH IN PERSON
SORRY. PLEASE PROCEED WILL
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M CHRISTY VALVE.
MORE THAN THIRTY THOUSAND
FIREFIGHTERS AND EMS PERSONNEL
IN CALIFORNIA I'M PROUD
SPONSORS OF SB THREE THIRTY
FIVE LITTLE HARD TO HEAR
GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHORED
CHAIRMAN A LITTLE HARD TO HEAR
I'M SORRY. IT'S PROBABLY NOT
HER FAULT INNOVATIVE YOU BE
DONE- AT SCHOOL. IS IT ON THIS
IS A BETTER IS BETTER. ANYWAY
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOU
INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE TO
TACKLE UNREASONABLE DENIALS AND
DELAYS IN THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM IT IS NOT
SPECULATIVE TO SUGGEST THE
DELAYS INCREASED COSTS FOR ALL
PARTIES IN THE SYSTEM. AND YET
OUR WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM
CONTINUES TO BE PLAGUED WITH
THESE DELAYS. IN EVERY ANALYSIS
PUT OUT BY THIS COMMITTEE
WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTIONS ARE PROBABLY JUST
APPROPRIATELY DESCRIBED AS A
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
PUTTING THEIR THUMB ON THE
SCALE. TO TIP TIP THE BURDEN OF
PROOF TOWARDS THE INJURED
WORKER. SUCH INTERVENTIONS ARE
FOR GOOD REASON FLICKR'S
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTIONS ARE
INVALUABLE PROTECTION. TO THE
KNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE THE
PERSONAL RISK FACED ON THE JOB
BY FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHER
WORKERS COVERED BY THESE
PRESUMPTIONS AND IMPORTANTLY
THE ADVANCE THE GOAL THAT WE
ALL SHARE OF GIVING
FIREFIGHTERS ANOTHER INJURED
WORKERS EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
RETURN TO THE JOB THEY LOVE.
REMARKABLY FIREFIGHTERS DON'T
EXPERIENCES DIFFERENCE WHEN
DEALING WITH A PRESUMPTIVE
INJURY OR ILLNESS. IT'S MORE
COMMONPLACE NOW FOR THE
EMPLOYER INSURER OR THIRD ARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. TO INITIALLY
DESIGNED TO DENY A PRESUMPTIVE
CLAIMS. FACING NO MATERIAL RISK
OF INCURRING PENALTIES OF THAT
CLAIM IS ALTERNATELY ACCEPTED.
NOT ONLY IS THE INJURY CLAIM
DENIED. BUT ALSO OT OFF UNTIL
THE NINETIETH DAY WITH LITTLE
TO NO INVESTIGATION REQUESTS
FOR MEDICAL RECORDS OR ANY
OTHER ANALYSIS DONE BY THE
EMPLOYER IN FACT. MANY OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS REGULARLY TO SEE
RECEIVED A CONDITIONAL THE NILE.
PENDING THE OUTCOME OF A QUEUE
OF ME. THIS IS THE VERY
PRACTICE OF THE OPPOSITION
SUGGEST WOULD OCCUR IF THIS
BILL PRESS PASSES. IT'S
HPPENING NOW BECAUSE THE
STATUS QUO. INJURED
FIREFIGHTERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
ARE CARRYING THE PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL BECAUSE OF AND
REASONABLE TO AND DENIALS
THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO SPEND
THEIR TIME. FIGHTING THEIR
INSTILL THIS DAN FIGHTING THE
SYSTEM. TO WHAT END. EVERY
DELAY HAS REAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
INJURED WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS MEASURE ACCURATELY ALIGNED
BY THE GERMAN ALIGNS THE
INCENTIVES TO ENSURE THE
SPECIAL NATURE OF THESE
INJURIES OR ILLNESSES ILLNESSES
IS PRESERVED. AND CONDITIONAL
DENIALS ONLY RESULT. WHEN THE
EMPLOYERS MADE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT TO INVESTIGATE THE
NATURE OF THE ENERGY INJURY.
SORRY IT'S HARD TO SPEAK IN A
MASK DON'T GET ME WRONG. THE
ADVERSARIAL PART OF THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION EXISTS. TO BE
EMPLOYED AND TO SCRUTINIZE
THOSE CLAIMS THAT HAVE A CLEAR
CONNECTION BEYOND WORK. IN A
PRESENT OR PRESENT A COMPLEXITY
THAT MUST BE EXAMINED BUT IN
PRACTICE THAT ADVERSARIAL
PROCESS. IS APPLIED ALL TOO
OFTEN IN EVERY SINGLE CASE AND
FIREFIGHTERS ARE FORCED TO WAIT
AND TO FIGHT. MANY TIMES. SB
THREE THIRTY FIVE IS CLEAR AND
SIMPLE MEASURE RESPECTS THE
VALUE OF A WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTION. REALIZE THE TIME
LINES TO MOVE AN INJURED WORKER
CLOSER TOWARDS RESOLUTION. OF
THEIR INJURY CLAIMS. MANAGERS
PROTECTION FOR THOSE WHO ARE
SEEKING MEDICAL TREATMENT.
WHILE THE CLAIM IS BEING
REVIEWED FOR THESE REASONS. WE
HEARD YOUR SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY FIVE TODAY THANK. THANK
YOU MS BOWMAN FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THIS AFTERNOON. WE
WILL NOW BEGIN WITH THEIR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE FIVE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE. THREE THREE I'M SORRY
THREE THREE FIVE. C. NINE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THREE FIVE. SEEN NONE. THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WANTING TO TESTIFY
THE AT THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATE YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THREE FIVE MOVIE
CAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE THREE FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU- MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE. TWO CALLERS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
AND CALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUAL WHO WILL CONTINUE.
NINE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANJERI
MEMBERS JENNIFER ROWE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM MINE NINETY ONE POINT
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CAITLIN THANK ON
BEHALF OF THE TRANSPORT WORKERS
OF AMERICA IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL OVER SUPPORT WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THIRTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM OUR
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
OUR SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. AND WE DO HAVE.
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES MR
JASON SCHMIDT SMELTS SCHMELTER
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I JUST
DON'T CARE THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED- THANK YOU- DECENT
SHELTER HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE THIRTY FIVE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION ON
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND PRISON
PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT. UNDER
WORKERS COMPENSATION LAW
EMPLOYERS ARE GIVEN NINETY DAYS
TO DETERMINE LIABILITY FOR
WORKPLACE INJURIES IF EMPLOYERS
DO NOT IMMEDIATELY ACCEPT
LIABILITY AND INSTEAD EXERCISED
THE RIGHT TO INVESTIGATE A
CLAIM THEN THEY MUST PROVIDE UP
TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH
OF MEDICAL TREATMENT TO THE
INJURED WORKER. DURING THE
PERIOD OF THAT INVESTIGATION SB
THREE THIRTY FIVE CUTS THAT
INVESTIGATION INTO FORTY FIVE
DAYS FOR MOST CLAIMS AND THIRTY
DAYS FOR CLAIMS THAT ARE
COVERED BY A PRESUMPTION FOR AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW FREQUENTLY
EMPLOYERS UTILIZE THE
INVESTIGATION PERIOD OUR CLIENT
PRISM EVALUATED. THEIR LAST
FIVE YEARS OF CLAIMS DATA THREE
THREE THOUSAND CLAIMS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE OU WITH
THE NUMBERS THAT THE SPONSOR
DID NOT 86% OF CLAIMS ARE
ACCEPTED IMMEDIATELY 13% OF
CLAIMS WERE DELAYED TO
INVESTIGATE FURTHER. 10% OF THE
CLAIMS OR ALTERNATELY DENIED
AFTER INVESTIGATION 3% OF THE
CLAIMS ARE ULTIMATELY ACCEPTED
AND 1% WERE ALTERNATELY DENIED
AND THEN ACCEPTED 1% SO WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN IT MEANS THAT
EMPLOYERS IMMEDIATELY ACCEPT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CLAIMS
AVOID UNNECESSARY DELAYS AND
ONLY A TINY PERCENTAGE OF OUR
DECISIONS END UP BEING
INCORRECT. SB THREE THIRTY FIVE
HAS THE EFFECT OF DEPRIVING
EMPLOYERS WITH ENOUGH TIME TO
CONDUCT A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION THIS IS NOT
NECESSARILY A SIMPLE AFFAIR
WE'VE GOT A INTERVIEW THE
INJURED WORKER EMPLOYERS
DOCTORS AND WITNESSES WE'VE GOT
TO OBTAIN RELEVANT MEDICAL
INSURANCE RECORDS WE HAVE TO
SCHEDULE MEDICAL LEGAL
EVALUATION WE HAVE TO COMPLETE
THE EVALUATION AND RECEIVED THE
REPORT AND OCCASIONALLY WE NEED
TO DEPOSE THE INJURED WORKER.
SB THREE THIRTY FIVE WOULD
DRASTICALLY CUT THE
INVESTIGATION CARRIED TIME FOR
EMPLOYERS BUT IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY CHANGE OTHER
PROVISIONS IN A LAW THAT WOULD
CONFLICT WITH THIS NEW LAW.
LET'S TOUCH ON THOSE VERY
BRIEFLY. PLAYER COACH FORTY SIX
TWO POINT ONE AND TWO TEN. FOR
THE STATE TO PROVIDE A PANEL
CUMAE ONCE PANEL'S BEEN
REQUESTED THE PARTIES ARE THEN
GIVEN TEN DAYS TO STRIKE A
DOCTOR FROM THE LAST. SECURE ME
THEN HAS SIXTY DAYS TO SET AN
APPOINTMENT AND ANOTHER THIRTY
DAYS TO FINISH THE EVALUATION.
WE STRUGGLE TO UNDERSTAND HOW
EMPLOYERS WOULD YOU EVER.
GENERATION INVESTIGATION UNDER
THE PROVISIONS OF SB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY FIVE. IT'S POORLY
CRAFTED AND WOULD CAUSE
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION TO
CALIFORNIA'S INJURED WORKERS
EMPLOYERS AND WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SCHMELZER WE
ALSO HAVE- ANOTHER SECOND LEAD
OPPOSITION TO WITNESS WITH FATE
FOR JUST ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
THIS BURGESS ADAM CARE PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBER
STATE BOARD IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY IS HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
THIRTY FIVE THE GOAL OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS IS TO HELP ALL
INJURED WORKERS RECEIVE
APPROPRIATE CARE AND SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND HELP THEM TO
RETURN TO WORK AT UNIVERSITY
FOR EVIL. YET WE ARE ALSO
ENCUMBERED BY FINANCIAL
REALITIES THAT REQUIRE CAREFUL
ADMINISTRATION OF PUBLIC
DOLLARS THAT WE WELCOME FURTHER
CONVERSATION FUNDS AT JANICE
AGENCY THAT SYSTEM DOES WORK TO
ENSURE THAT ANY WORKER WITH AN
INDUSTRIAL INJURY RECEIVED
MEDICAL TREATMENT AT NO COST TO
THE WORKER ALL INJURED WORKERS
ARE ENTITLED TO IMMEDIATE
MEDICAL CARE AT THEIR
EMPLOYER'S EXPENSE AND WHILE
THAT CARRIED BEING PROVIDED
ADMINISTRATORS ARE REQUIRED TO
CONFIRM THAT ONE BE HONEST
THIRTY THREE DESIGNATE AND Q.
THAT IT WORK RELATED. TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN EMPLOYER
FUNDED TREATMENT IS AVAILABLE
UNTIL THE CLAIM IS ACCEPTED OR
DENIED TO SHORTEN INVESTIGATION
PERIOD AND THIS BILL MAY FORCE
I COMPATIBILITY DECISIONS PRIOR
TO RECEIVING MEDICAL RECORDS OR
EVALUATING POSITION REPORTS
WITHOUT WHICH A CLAIM CANNOT
CONCEIVABLY BE APPROVED AS YOU
HEARD FROM THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
THAT JUSTIN IS NOT CURRENTLY
ABLE TO COMPLY WITH THE TIME
FRAMES PROPOSED BY THE BILL NOR
IS THERE SUFFICIENT DATA THAT
IT'S NECESSARY. ULTIMATELY WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
ABBREVIATED TIME FRAME WILL
INCREASE CLAIM DENIALS FOSTER
INCREASED AND UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION TRY THAT CLAIM COSTS
AND ULTIMATELY. NEGATIVELY
IMPACT INJURED WORKERS- THIS
BILL IF MORTGAGE THAN OFFICE.
THE PROPOSAL. A LOT ANY OVER
FOR AFTER BENNETT. THAT INCLUDE
RECEIVING THEIR FULL SALARY TAX.
AND RETIRED. WHICH ALSO PROVIDE
TAX FREE BENEFITS WITH
VIRTUALLY NO BURDEN OF PROOF
THAT. THE ILLNESS OR INJURY AND
EVEN CAUSED BY WORK GIVEN THEIR
PRESUMPTIVE NATURE. ACCORDINGLY
THESE POLICY CHANGES MERIT
CAUTION DATA AND MORE ABOUT
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT UNTIL
THAT TIME RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
BURGESS. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE DO WE HAVE ANY
TWO OR THREE CNN. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE THREE FIVE.
C. NINE. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST. MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE THREE FIVE
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN. THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR HE WOULD PLEASE
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE FIVE PEOPLE. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE OPN THE LINES AND CALL
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES
INDIVIDUAL WILL CONTINUE. THANK
YOU NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASHLEY HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIRTY CAD ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE THREE FIVE. NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON YOUR
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE SITUATION OF
CERTIFICATE OR COMMENTS OF THE
MAIN WITNESSES- IN OPPOSITION
THANKS. NINE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON SILVER MULE AND
REPRESENTING ACCLAMATION
INSURANCE MANAGEMENT SERVICES
AND ALLIED MANAGED CARE ALSO IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON RYAN SUTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE THREE FIVE. THANK YOU. IN
OUR LAST MINUTE COMMENT IS NINE
SEVENTY SIX POINT SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR- IF YOU
WOULD CHECK THE LINE TO ONE
MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OUR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THIRTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
WE DO HAVE BEEN LINE IN Q. OKAY
JUST A MOMENT WHILE WE HAVE THE
MINIMUM NUMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR. NINE ONE OH ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
APOLOGIES MADAM CHAIR EDUARDO
MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT YOU. THANK YOU
OUR MODERATOR THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS
DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
THANK YOU. RIGHT WHEN YOU'RE
READY I'LL HAVE TO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU CENTERED AROUND
CENTER CORTESE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MA'AM SURE
OF THEM COLLEAGUES THE
PROVISIONS IN SB THREE THIRTY
FIVE TAKEN TOGETHER RESPOND
DIRECTLY TO THE WIDESPREAD AND
TOTALLY UNREASONABLE TACTICS OF
DELAY AND DENIAL USED BY FAR
TOO MANY EMPLOYERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE RESULTS OF THESE
TACTICS OF THE WORKERS
SUFFERING WITHOUT CARE AND IN
SOME CASES EVEN LOSING THEIR
LIVES. INCLUDING THOSE VERY
WORKERS WHO SEEK TO MAINTAIN
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY QUITE FRANK
THIS LINE THE CURRENT
PRESUMPTION MODEL.
ITS ORIGINAL
INTENT. THANK YOU THE BILL IS
OUT OF FORTY ONE. WE. THANK YOU
VERY PASSED THE GAVEL BACK TO
SENATOR CORTESE. THE COMMUTER
BUS TOUR WE WILL PROCEED WITH
ORIGIN TO PHONE RELATED TO UP
BY THE KILL- NECK WHICH USE ONE
ITEM S. B. SIX FOUR FOUR THESE
ARE EMOTIONAL CONSENT OF. THOSE
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED- POOL
AS FOR A ROLE CALL VOTE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. SENATOR CORY. I
SENATOR CORTEZ THE SO- CHIU
BOGUE. SENATOR- CHIU ABOAGYE
SENATE TORONTO TO DORADO HI
SENATOR LAYERED HI SENATOR I
SAN NEWMAN ALL RIGHT SO NEWMAN
I. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BILL WAS FIVE TO THE BILL IS
OUT YOU FOR. BECAUSE CALENDARS
OUT. WE'LL COME BACK NOW ITEM
TWO ON THE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IN THE IS- SB THREE
NINE- CENTER GROVE BILLS GROW
WELCOME. YOU ARE WELCOME TO
PRESENT THE TIME THANK YOU MAY
CHAIR- A MISTER CHAIR MADAM
VICE AND AS THIRTY NINE MOST
THE PER. AGAINST CLAIMS FILED
WITH THE EMPLOYMENT DEPARTMENT
FOR AND BENEFITS TO PREVENT
THESE BENEFITS FROM GOING IN L.
RE. THE CURRENT IN CURSEIN.
FOLLOWING THE FED GOVERNMENT
THREE TO COPE WITH IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY CALIBER TASK THE
EDT WITH DISTURBING THE CARES
ACT FRIENDS. THROUGH A NEWLY
CREATED PANDEMIC AND ASSISTANCE
AND EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM HOWEVER DESPITE HAVING
BEEN WARNED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL RISK OF FRAUD DDT WAS
NOT PREPARED TO PREVENT OR
ADDRESS FRAUDULENT CLAIMS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT. TO MAKE MATTERS
WORSE THE STATE AUDIT REVEALED
THAT THE E. D. D. M. THAT THE
EDT WAS TOLD ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL PROBLEM IN THE RISK
FACTORS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN AND THEY DID NOTHING TO
PREVENT THIS FRAUD. MANY OF
THESE CLAIMS WERE FILED IN
INMATES- FILED BY INMATES OR
THEIR ACCOMPLICES SOME WERE
FILED USING THE IDENTITIES OF
WELL KNOWN CONVICTED MURDERERS
LIKE SCOTT PETERSON OTHER
EXAMPLES OF CONVICTED KILLERS-
THAT HAD CLAIMS FILED UNDER
THEIR NAMES INCLUDE ROYAL CLARK
WHO WAS CONVICTED OF KILLING
TWO YOUNG GIRLS IN ASSAULTING
ANOTHER. IN SUSAN EUBANKS WHO
SHOT HER FOUR SONS AGES. FOUR
THREE FOURTEEN. ALL THE WHILE
BEEN. WE'RE DELAY BY THE E. D.
D. TO OUR SINK MOMS FATHER. AND
WERE FORCED TO DRAW THEIR SAY
ACCOUNTS TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES AND PUT FOOD ON THEIR
TABLE. FRAUDULENT CLAIMS THAT
WERE NOT WARRANTED TO BE PAID
SHOULD NOT BE AWARDED TO PEOPLE
WHO DO NOT DESERVE THEM. AT THE
TIME THE FRAUD WAS DISCOVERED
IN CALIFORNIA THIRTY FIVE OTHER
STATES HAD ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
SOME SORT OF FRAUD PROTECTION.
TO ADDRESS THESE INMATES SCAMS
CALIFORNIA DID NOT AND THAT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE. WE CAN AND MUST
DO BETTER IN OUR STATE MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WERE LEFT HIGH
AND DRY. AS THE EDG FAILED TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE SERVICE AND WE
ALL HEARD ABOUT IT FROM OUR
DISTRICT OFFICES. AS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THIS SORT OF FRAUD DOES NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS JUST LOST THEIR
JOB AT NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
BECAUSE OF THE CODE RESPONSE.
CALIFORNIA MUST DO BETTER AND
THERE'S NO ROOM FOR ANYTHING
ELSE SB THIRTY NINE WILL
PROTECT TAXPAYER FUNDS WHILE
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
GO. TO ELIGIBLE UNEMPLOYED
INDIVIDUALS BY MAINTAINING THAT
THE EDG CONDUCT REGULAR CROSS
MATCHING. OF THEIR RECORDS WITH
DATA PROVIDED BY THE CDC ARE AT
LEAST EVERY NINETY DAYS. THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE DATA TO ONLY
INCLUDE INFORMATION OF CURRENT
INMATES. IT ALSO REQUIRES EDIE
NOTIFY THE DOJ AND CDC ARE IF
THEY DISCOVER EVIDENCE OF FRAUD
IN THEIR CROSS MATCHING. PRIOR
TO TODAY'S HEARING I WORKED
WITH SENATOR SKINNER AND WIENER
TO NARROW THE BILL TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RELATED TO THE
SENSITIVE NATURE NATURE OF THE
INFORMATION. THAT WOULD BE
SHARED BETWEEN CDC R. N. E. D.
D. THE APRIL FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENTS WERE RESULTED THIS
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND I
BELIEVE THEY SUFFICIENTLY
ADDRESS. THEIR CONCERNS AND
FURTHER ANY AND FURTHER MY
EFFORTS TO REBUILD THE TRUST
AND- EXPECTATIONS THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE IN THEIR STAY
A GOVERNMENT S. B. TH NINE.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WAS
VOTED OUT OF PUBLIC SAFETY ON A
FOUR ZERO VOTE FOR THESE
REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
RESPECTFULLY. JOINING ME TODAY
ON THE PHONE IS CYNTHIA ZIMMER
KERN COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTY NINE. YES FIRM READ
WITNESSES A BILL WILSON. ARE
YOU THERE. YEAH I AM GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- THIS ISN'T USE THEM I
AM THE DISTRICT OCCURRING CAL.
AND I'M JOINING THIS TO SHARE
MY EXPERIENCES PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE FRAUD.
THE PANDEMIC HAS HAD EIGHT ZERO
NAY. ASSET ON PUBLIC SHE HELLO.
IN TOWN WHERE WE HAVE HAD
UNFORTUNATELY THE HIGHEST
HOMICIDE RATE PER CAPITA IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SEVERAL YEARS
RUNNING. HUIZAR DEADLIEST YEAR
ON RECORD IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX HOMICIDES
TWENTY TWENTY ALSO BROUGHT US
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT FRAUD ON
TAXPAYER FUNDS IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY WITH WIDESPREAD ET
FRAUD WE SAW THIS FRAUD NOT
ONLY IN OUR COMMUNITIES WITHIN
OUR COUNTY JAIL AND IN STATE
PRISONS. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
LOCAL AND STATE INMATES ARE
INVOLVED. ORANGE COUNTY HAS
BEEN PRETTY IMPACTED BY EDT
FRAUD BECAUSE OUR COUNTY HAS
FIVE STATE PRISONS. MORE THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND MANY PROSECUTORS
INVESTIGATORS IN MY OFFICE
DESPITE IS HAVING SUCH A HIGH
HOMICIDE RATE THIS YEAR HAVE
BEEN REASSIGNED FROM OTHER
UNITS WITHIN THE OFFICE TO WORK
EXCLUSIVELY ON EDT FRAUD. AT A
LOSS TO TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATED
WITH EDT FRAUD CONTINUES TO
INCREASE AS WE LEARN ABOUT THE
MASSIVE SCALE OF THIS ABUSE
CURRENT ESTIMATES PLACE THE
AMOUNT OF LOSS TO CALIFORNIA.
AT THIRTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
MANY OF CALIFORNIANS MOST
VIOLENT INMATES TO SENATOR
GIRLS THAT STATED HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM THE FRAUD IN IT
AND IT CERTAINLY MAKES IT
HARDER FOR US TO ASSERT THAT
CRIME DOES NOT PAY. ANALYSTS
CROSS MATCHING REQUIREMENTS
LIKE THOSE PROPOSED HERE ARE
IMPLEMENTED CALIFORNIA RISKS
MAKING THE SAME MISTAKES THAT
LEFT IT OPEN TO BE PICK
POCKETED BY CRIMINALS ON AN
UNPRECEDENTED SCALE. S. TO DO
SERIES OF PUBLIC FUNDS WE ALL
OWE A DUTY TO ENSURE THAT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE PROTECTED
FROM ABUSE AND FRAUD THEREFORE
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB.
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY WILL- COME NO- WHO IS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THE BILL IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. PUSHED UP
FOR TWO THIRDS CASE. HELLO SEEN
NONE. WE WILL LOOK TO YOUR FULL
ROOM AND- WE SEE NO WHEN
THEY'RE TO PILUM TOMORROW S.
MODERATE. TO QUEUE UP ANY SORT
TESTIMONY. ON SB. THREE NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY NINE YOU MY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM MINE
NINETY THREE POINT NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE AND SENATE
BILL THIRTY THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR MEMBERS NICOLE BORNEMANN ON
THE OF AMBER COUNTY AND COURT
OF S. B. NINE. NINE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND SHALL
REMEMBER FIRST HE DOS BEHALF OF
CURRENT BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
INTO AT THE NINE THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL- GO BACK TO THE SAME
PROCESS IN TERMS OF OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO IDENTIFIED LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES I
UNDERSTAND- SO WE WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB THIRTY NINE IN
THE ROOM. SEEN NONE HELLO TO
THE OVERFLOW ROOM. AS SEEN
NOBODY THERE TO TESTIFY WILL
COME BACK TO THE MODERATOR NASA
MODERATED A Q. UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE AND LET ME
JUST STATE THAT THE PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPANT PHONE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO I KNOW THAT
THAT'S NOT BEING DISPLAYED ON
OUR SCREEN SO IF YOU'RE WAITING
TO TESTIFY. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO
WITH AN ACCESS CODE OF FIVE
ZERO ZERO SIX THREE ZERO EIGHT
BACK TO THE MODERATOR FOR. A
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LATEST
GENTLEMAN YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE TWENTY FOUR
LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS IMPACT
FROM THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE PPL OF ON BEHALF OF
WEEK LATE OPPOSITION. AND IT
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR THAT
WILL BE US BACK. TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM THE
CENTER DRAWS A- THANK YOU FOR.
FIVE OBVIOUSLY AS THE AUTHOR NO
THE WAS A IN ORDER RECEIVED
MANY OF THE URGENCY OF GETTING
THE AND FOUGHT THAT IMPACT
EVERYBODY- HOWEVER I HAVE A
SEVERAL CONCERN. OF PRIME
AROUND OF THE DUKE. OF THESE
AND WHO COULD BE DENIED.
WITHOUT BOMB HAVING SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE THAT THEY'LL JUST GET
CAUGHT UP IN THE- IN THE
WHIRLWIND OF IT ALL- AT THE E.
D. D. HEARING THAT WE HAD A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO. MONTHS
AGO I THINK IT. IT WAS MADE
VERY CLEAR THAT THE FRAUD CASES
I KNOW IN THE ANALYSIS IT SAYS
THAT- EDT PAID BILLIONS THIRTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FRAUDULENT KAMES AT CLAIMS.
THAT MONEY WENT TO INMATES WHO
ARE INELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THESE
BENEFITS WHAT WAS VERY CLEAR
FROM THE HEARING IS THAT 9295%
OF THE FRAUD CASES WERE NOT
ATTRIBUTED TO. ANYONE WHO HAD
BEEN INCARCERATED DURING THAT
TIME SO OVER TRUE BEAUTY IN THE
PERCENTAGE OF FRAUD CASES. ARE
SO DRAMATICALLY I THINK IS AN
INCORRECT THING TO PUT FORWARD
CONSIDERING THAT WHAT WE REALLY
WANT IS TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
ANYONE WHO BROKE THE LAW
ANYBODY WHO FILED A FRAUDULENT
CAME ON A CLAIM. SO I'M
CONCERNED THAT THAT BECOMES THE
DRIVING FORCE HERE THAT- YOU
KNOW WOULD LEAD US TO DENY
LEGITIMATE BY ANYONE WHO WAS
EITHER INCARCERATED- AT THE
TOP- AT SOME POINT IN THE PAST
A RELEASE FROM CARS SERRATION
OR MAYBE NOT EVEN EVER HAVING
BEEN INCARCERATED- I DON'T
THINK THAT'S THE CORRECT
APPROACH TO TAKE ON THIS. SO I-
I WOULD- I THINK THAT THERE'S
TO BE DONE FOR TWO THE DUE
PROCESS OF A CLAIM IN REGARD OF
WHO CLAIM IS- THAT. WE MAKE.
THAT WE'RE NOT THE NINE THAT
WHEN I TURN AROUND AND DO YOU
NINE- PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
LEGITIMATE CLAIMS SO I- I
WOULD- VERY NARROW SOME. ON THE
BILL IF- IF THERE WERE IS
ASSURANCE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ADD DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS- SO THAT- EVERYONE
HAS THE SAME RIGHT. TO COLLECT
THE BENEFITS AND WITHOUT SORT
OF BEING THROWN INTO. INTO. THE
BATCH OF OTHER PEOPLE. THANK
YOU AND MISTER OUR MAIN SPAHN
JERRY FOR RESERVE YOUR COM AND
YOUR- I'M SORRY IF I MISSED HER.
THE THAT WAS MY AND- MIND AT
SHOULD READ THAT THERE'S THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF ESTIMATED
TOTAL FRAUD OUT THERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITFRAUD
THERE'S AN ESTIMATE OF ALMOST
TWO BILLION. I'M OF INMATE
FRAUD A PERFECT EXAMPLE- IT IS
JUST RECENTLY THERE WAS A AN
INDIVIDUAL IN FRESNO WITH IT-
JASON VERTS AND IT IS A FRESNO
FORTY FIVE YEAR OLD ANNA
POWERS. IS AN INMATE AT A
CENTRAL FACILITY IN THE WOMEN'S
FACILITY IN CHOWCHILLA SHE
SUBMITTED FRAUDULENT CLAIMS AND
ON THE INITIAL EMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE BENEFIT PROGRAM AND
IT DID SHOW THAT- A HUNDRED
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS WAS PAID
TO THOSE BENEFITS NOW THAT'S A
SMALL PORTION. OF THE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OF ESTIMATED
FRIED- THAT'S IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM- BUT THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN
PROVEN SO FAR. AND BUT THAT
HUNDRED AND THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS NO MATTER HOW SMALL IT
IS COMPARED TO THE TOTAL NUMBER
IS STILL A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY FOR MY CONSTITUENTS
FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS THAT WERE
DELAYED BENEFITS- THE OTHER
THING IS THAT. THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN THAT SENATOR
SKINNER SAYS SKINNER AND
SENATOR WIENER AND I WORKED ON.
IT NARROWED IT SO IT WASN'T A
BLANKET JUST REPORT ONE TIME
CDC ARE- REPORTS THOSE TWO EDT-
EVERY NINETY DAYS SO THAT WHEN
PEOPLE GET OUT- IF THERE'S
ELIGIBLE FOR BENEFITS- ONCE
THEY GET EMPLOYED OR THEY CAN
GO BACK ON AN EMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. PRIOR TO
BEING INCARCERATED WITH THE
DOLLARS THAT THEY ORANGE PRIOR
TO BE INCARCERATED THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO DO THAT BECAUSE
THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
AND WOULD BE VALIDATED FOR JUST
THAT NINETY DAYS. AS FAR AS THE
COMMENT THAT YOU MADE ABOUT-
OTHER THAN INDIVIDUALS A
INCARCERATED IN CDCR DURING
THAT NINETY DAY PERIOD. I DON'T
SEE HOW ANY OTHER SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS TO BE PROVIDED
TO THE EDT OFFICE BECAUSE
THEY'RE GETTING THEM DIRECTLY
FROM CDC. ARE SO IF AND I YES
YOU KNOW THERE COULD BE AN
INVERSE NUMBER. AND THE MEASURE-OF THIS SECURE NUMBERS OR I
WOULD SAY HI. HI READERS IS
KARENA WOULD BE THOSE OF THE IN
CARS. AND THEY WOULD BE ON.
NINETY DAY PERIOD- PRIOR TO THE
REPORT REQUEST. SYNDROMES OF
ANYTHING ELSE ON. AND I JUST I
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE OTHER
ALL AMENDMENTS THAT CAN BE
TAKEN TO FURTHER PROTECT THE
DUE PROCESS SO BOB BE
SUBMITTING TO THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE AND MY MAN MY INTENTION
IS NOT TO DENY ANYONE WHO'S
ELIGIBLE FOR BENEFITS TO HAVE
BENEFITS IT'S A 1100% EMPLOYER
FUNDED PROGRAM THE CARES ACT
CAME FROM TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND
IT'S JUST I FEEL AS LEGISLATORS
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO PROTECT TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
AND HAVING THE HIGHEST- PRISON
POPULATION IN MY DISTRICT WITH-
SEVERAL PRISONS IT'S BECOMING
EVIDENT THAT MORE AND MORE
FRAUD IS BEING COMMITTED AND
PERPETRATED AGAINST OUR OUR TAX
PAYING CITIZENS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE BENEFITS
THAT ARE NOT GETTING THESE
BENEFITS AND- AS A LARGE NUMBER
OF DOLLARS AND I REALIZE THAT
TWO BILLION IS A FAR CRY FROM
THIRTY BILLION BUT STILL TWO
BILLION DOLLARS WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT A LOT OF OUR INDIVIDUAL.
CONSTITUENTS IN OUR DISTRICTS
THAT ARE ENTITLED TO BENEFITS
WOULD RECEIVE THOSE BENEFITS IF
THEY WEREN'T BEING ILLEGALLY
GIVEN TO AND INMATE CENTER CARS
RATED THAT HAVE FILED
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. THANK YOU OF
ANY OTHER COME QUITE. SO AT THE
POINT NEWMAN A VERY TO THE YOU-
AS CHAIR- SILVA I'M GLAD HEAR
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO WORK
WITH SAN RAZA MAKE SURE THE TO
PRO. MATTERS HERE I'D BUT
BEYOND THAT THIS IS A REASON
BILL I THINK I AGREE WITH THAT
TO BE DOLLARS IS. REAL MONEY
BUYS I'LL BE SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING. THANK YOU SIR. VIDEO
HERE ON THE- ON COMMITTEE. OF
THIS. SOONER TO SUCH WILL S.
YOU YOUR FOR A COUPLE TO. A
MEMO THAT YOU WORK. ON.
ASSEMBLY AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO
WE DON'T HAVE AN COMMITTEE OF
SURPRISE. TO TODAY WITH- SOME
OF THE SENATE THAT YOU READ TO-
ARE THE IT'S- UP. TEXT SO TO
SPEAK SOME THAT YOU CAN CALL
OUT COURSE. HER TODAY DON'T
KNOW IT WITH THE SAME CONCERN
CENTERED AWAY SPEAKING TO ENTER
TO DO. OR A THAT YOU DO IT
MAYOR IN- WHICH WILL SEEM TO.
PERHAPS ADDRESS SOME CONCERNS.
OF OUR CALL. FROM LOS ANGELES
BUT I WANT TO YOU DO MORE SO.
FOR SIR CROSS MATCH THEM TO SEE
IF THERE WERE INDIVIDUALS
INCARCERATED THAT WERE DRYING
BENEFITS- AS SENATORS WIENER
AND SKINNER. DATE I HAD SOME
SUGGESTIONS THAT WE SHOULD
NARROW THAT IT ONLY HAVE A TIME
FRAME SO THAT SOMEBODY WAS IN
CDC ARE TEN YEARS AGO OR FIVE
YEARS AGO OR TWO YEARS AGO
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THAT TYPE
OF- REPORTING TO EDT. SO WE
NARROWED IT TO NINETY DAYS AND
ET DE HAS TO REQUEST THE
INFORMATION FROM CDC ARE IN
ORDER TO HAVE A PROVIDED TO EDT.
THE WHOLE THING AND I DO HAVE
THE LANGUAGE. IT'S THE EIGHT
ARE IN THE BILL YES THANK YOU
FIRST MIRACLE I REAL SO THAT
THE WHAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED IS
IN THE VERSION OF THE THAT WE-
RECEIVED HERE. BEFORE US TODAY
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT ANYTHING
ELSE THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IS A CLOSE SO. I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AGAIN THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
FRAUD IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY I REALIZED THAT. IF
THIS WAS FULLY IMPLEMENTED AND
FULLY PROCESSED AND FULLY UP IT
WOULD. IT COULD HAVE THE
POTENTIAL OF ELIMINATING ALMOST
TWO BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
FRIED. I REALIZE THAT SAID IN A
SMALLER NUMBER LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
POINTED OUT IN THE THIRTY
BILLION. BUT I STILL THINK IT'S
REAL MANY AND IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT DOLLAR AMOUNT FOR
CONSTITUENTS THAT- PAY THIS
MONEY INTO THE SYSTEM. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR AND-
MEDIVATION OF PETITIONS
POPULARLY BELIEVE YOUR CALL OF
THE BILL JUNE. I WOULD BE MORE
THAN HAPPY IN OUR TO MOVE THE
BILL YES. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU. THE CONSOLE MASS FOR
ROLL CALL VOTE TIME. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT- BE RE REFER TO
THE CAN. ON A PER. SENATOR
COURT HE- I. AM RECORD HAS THE
HIGH SENATOR OCHO. I SENATOR-
CHAU POGUE HI SENATOR ALSO.
SENATOR BARACK I SENATE LAYERED
HI. SENATOR LEHRER I SENATOR.
HI SENATOR NEWMAN. GOOD THING
SENATORS RECALL THE NINETEEN
CENTER YOU MAY STEP UP IN
PRESENT WELCOME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SENATORS. IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY- I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT S. B. SEVEN OH
FIVE A BILL THAT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD. IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO FOR A BORDER
RELATIONS COUNCIL TO JOINTLY
FORM A STUDY GROUP OF SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS TO ANALYZE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES. AND
OPPORTUNITIES ARISING FROM THE
PRESENCE OF A LARGE BI NATIONAL
STUDENT POPULATION AND
WORKFORCE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER.
CALIFORNIA'S MANY OF US IN OUR
IS PART OF THE WORLD'S MOST.
IMPACTFUL WORLD ECONOMIES AND
WE HAVE A REGION WITH IN
CALIFORNIA COMBINED WITH
MEXICO- OF WHICH OF. YOU KNOW
IF YOU ADDED UP ALL THE BORDER
STATES ALONG THE US MEXICO
BORDER. THE BORDER STATES BEING
OF THE STATE'S OF MEXICO AND-
UNITED STATES THAT ARE- JOIN
EACH OTHER TO BORDER. THE
STATE'S JOINTLY WOULD CON THE
THIRD LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. HEARING CALIFORNIA WHAT
WE CALL THE LESS SANTEE
CORRIDOR WHICH IS FROM LOS
ANGELES TO THE QUANTUM. THIS
CALL REGION WOULD HAVE THE LAW
ELEVENTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. THE PASSAGE OF THE NORTH
AMERICAN FREE TRADE AGREEMENT
LED TO THE INTEGRATION OF THE
US AND MET MEXICAN ECONOMIES
THROUGH INCREASED BORDER
MANUFACTURING AND TRADE. OVER
FIVE MILLION US JOBS ARE
SUPPORTED BY TRADE WITH MEXICO
FORMING PART OF A COMPLEX
NETWORK OF CROSS BORDER SUPPLY
CHAINS IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
TO WAIT TRADING GOODS BETWEEN
MEXICO IN THE UNITED STATES
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY FROM.
EIGHTY ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE. TO
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT. I'M
BILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY IN
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA
EXPORTS TO MEXICO AMOUNTED TO
TWENTY FOUR OVER TWENTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
IMPORTED. OVER FORTY SEVEN
BILLION IN GOODS FROM MEXICO.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
GROUND ZERO FOR ADVANCED CROSS
BORDER MANUFACTURING AND TRADE
WE HAVE NOT TAKEN THE
APPROPRIATE STEPS NEEDED TO
PREPARE THE WORKFORCE NEEDED TO
SUSTAIN OUR BY NATIONAL ECONOMY
RESEARCH SHOWS A CALIFORNIA
COULD STAND TO BENEFIT GREATLY
FROM PREPARING OUR WORKFORCE.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE WITH
THE SIGNING OF THE U. S. MCA.
FOR THE US BORDER STATES THE
INCREASE OF EMPLOYMENT AND GDP
COULD RANGE FROM SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION JOBS CONFERENCE NINE
DOLLARS TO ONE HUNDRED I'M I
MEAN I'M SORRY FROM SIXTY NINE
TWO HUNDRED FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDED TO GDP. WHAT
THE LARGEST IMPACT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT THESE
BENEFITS CANNOT BE REALIZED IF
WE DO NOT ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MILLIONS OF KIDS AND YOUNG
ADULTS. THAT ARE FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS BECAUSE OF
THE COMPLEX HISTORY BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO TODAY
THERE ARE NONE S. BEST
ESTIMATED HALF A MILLION MINERS
IN MEXICO WITH TIES TO THE
UNITED STATES THAT'S WHAT SOME
WHAT SOME FORMER OTHER THESE
ARE U. S. CITIZENS LIVING IN
MEXICO. AND MILLIONS OF
STUDENTS FROM MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS HOUSEHOLDS ENROLLED
IN SCHOOLS BETWEEN MEXICO AND
THE UNITED STATES THE STUDENTS
COMPRISE A SEGMENT OF A GROWING
BI NATIONAL STUDENT POPULATION
INCLUDES STUDENTS ACROSS THE
BORDER EVERY DAY TO ATTEND
SCHOOL. STUDENTS OF MEXICAN
DESCENT AND COLLEGE STUDENTS
TAKEN BY NATIONAL EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES AMONG OTHERS APTLY
CALLED THE STUDENTS WE SHARE.
THIS IS A POPULATION OF
STUDENTS SORT OF EXPERIENCE
FUNCTIONING IN A MORE GLOBAL
SOCIETY AND YET THEY REPORT
LOWER EDUCATIONAL ASPIRATIONS
AND THEIR PEERS BY BRINGING AND
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS A BI
NATIONAL EDUCATION WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. TO FORM A SO GROUP
A PLAN TO IMPROVE EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES. AND WORK FOR
DEVELOPMENT UP. CAL COULD REAP
THE BENEFITS THAT COME A GROUP.
BY NATIONAL ECONOMY WELL
ADDRESSING THE INEC EXPERT BY
LAW. IN SEGMENT OUR. MMHM AT
THE POINT WHERE IN WE HAVE NOT
TAKEN THE APPROPRIATE STEPS TO
PREPARE THE WORKFORCE NEEDED TO
SET SUPPORT OUR BY NATIONAL
ECONOMY BY DEVELOPING A PLAN WE
CAN TURN WE CAN IN TURN ADDRESS
CHALLENGES FACED BY A BI
NATIONAL STUDENT POPULATION AND
BUILD THE WORKFORCE NEEDED TO
BUILD A MORE EFFECTIVE AND
EQUITABLE CROSS BORDER ECONOMY
IN DOING SO WE NOT ONLY SUPPORT
THE CHALLENGES FACED BY THE
STUDENTS BUT WE ENSURE THAT
THEY BECOME PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS
OF THE ECONOMY THROUGH AMPLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO USE THEIR
SKILLS TO JOIN OUR WORKFORCE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
BILL TODAY WE HAVE COMMENTARY
AND SOME OF THE COMMENTS AND
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS A KEY MAN OF YES IN
YOUR MARTINEZ HIS THE COURT OF
INTER BUSINESS AFFAIRS AT THE
SENEGAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
SHE'D LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS IF SUCH A CHARM WOULD
ALLOW. THANK YOU SENATOR WEST.
SENATE QUARTERS HE HAD TO STEP
OUT SO I BE OUT FOR THROUGH WE
DO HAVE A LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS
HE MAY YES THE AUTUMN ARE YOU A
THE LINE. YES I AM. PLEASED SAM
I'M OF. THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LIVED HERE WE CHAMBER
COMMERCE AND AREN'T BUT BUYING
COME. WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT
AS. SEVEN OH FIVE. WE ARE THAT
THE BILL WILL PLAN SIGNAL ROLE
IN BUILDING A MARIN. ECONOMICAL
BY ADDRESSING THE PRESS AND I'M
GOING TO. EXPERIENCE THAT BY A
GIRL BY NASH WORK. AND
POPULATION. CALLING PURPOSE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR TWO ONE FIFTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS- WHERE
THAT HOW DO YOU THAT WE DO
REPRESENTS A TREMENDOUS GROWTH
WHICH FOR ALL INTO. INCLUDING
MANUFACTURING. ARE YOUR
CLEANTECH AND MARK. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF STRATEGIC PLAN
TO OUR COSTA WORKS AND
OPPORTUNITY WELL ALL BE COULD
TO. OUR BRAND ECONOMY. ZHILI
UNDER COVER OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC ENERGY STATE BECAUSE
COMPETITOR. COMPETITIVENESS
AMALA DRESSING IN. EXPERIENCE
WITHIN COMMUNITY. WE TAKE A
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK CENTER
WHERE WITH A AGAIN FOR LEADER.
FORTY TWO OH THREE TO HAVE ANY
WITNESSES SEEN NINE. DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN TWENTY FORTY
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE. SCENE NINE THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY THE OF THE
TELECONFERENCE ARVEST MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE. WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S SEVEN ZERO FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN. ZERO FIVE.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO COMMENT
IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IF
YOU DON'T MIND MADAME MODERATOR
SHE WOULD CHECK THE LINES ONE
MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR SB SEVEN
ZERO FIVE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF B.
SEVEN ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN Q. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL IT SAID THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. AND I BELIEVE. WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
BACKTRACKED. PERFECT WONDERFUL.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN OPPOSITION FOR FORTY
TWO OR THREE C. NINE WILL MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY AND WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE SEEN NONE. THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WANTING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR THIS. MATTER
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS GOING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SB SEVEN
ZERO FIVE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE. WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THINK ABOUT
A MURDER IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
CHECKING LINES ONE MORE TIME
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE PLEASE. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL IT WILL.
YEAH WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR.
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. BOB AND
I JUST WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR I
THINK- THIS IS REALLY LOOKING
AT THE SITUATION. AHEAD OF AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE PROBABLY
SHOULD BE BEEN DONE THEM BEFORE
RIGHT IN TERMS OF THE IMPACT.
BUT I THINK WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED. WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE
THE MEN WOMEN AND YOUTH WHO
COME ACROSS THE BORDER TAKE FOR
GRANTED WHAT THEY DO. AND WHAT
WE DO FOR EACH OTHER IS TWO
DIFFERENT NATIONS SO. I REALLY
THINK THIS IS A- GREAT IDEA OF-
OF USING THE RESOURCES FROM
EACH SIDE THE TALENT THE
COMMITMENT THAT WE ALL HAVE.
AND THAT'S NOT USUALLY. THE
PICTURE THAT WE PAINT OUR FROM
THE BORDER. YOU KNOW IT'S
USUALLY ALL THOSE PEOPLE ARE
COMING OVER HERE TO THE SIDE
AND- THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO OFFER THEIR RUNNING. AND
IT'S JUST SUCH A LIE SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING ON BEHALF OF BOTH
COUNTRIES. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS OF
CENTER LAND ADAM CHAIR. THE
MOTION IN ORDER AND IF WE DON'T
HAVE ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM OUR SENATOR EVEN
THOUGH. I JUST CHANGE MY
POSITION ON ON CERTAIN BILLS-
AND JUDICIARY. WELL WELL
SENATOR BEN HUESO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU IN THE MEMBERS FOR I THANK
YOU CENTER THE REST FOR
COMMENTS AND THANK IN OTHERS-
THE MEMBERS FOR THEIR SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU CENTER A HIGHWAY SO.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM CENTER
NEWMAN TO MOVE. WELCOME SAID.
FROM CENTER LARRY EMOTION FROM
CENTER LAYERED TO MOVE IT. L.
S. B. SEVEN ZERO FIVE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BY FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SEPARATE.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR CORTESE HI REPORTER THE
AYE SENATOR CHOKE HI AND- CHAU
BOGOTA BY SENATOR ALSO HI
SENATOR ALSO HI CENTER LAYERED
HI UNDER LAYERED HI SENATOR
NEWMAN HI SENATOR NEWMAN HI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THE BILL IS OUT WITH FIVE TWO
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW PASSED THE GAVEL BACK
TO OUR CHAIR. THANKS AGAIN
MEMBERS SHERMAN NEXT BILL- ON
OUR AGENDA IS S. B. TWO THIRTY
TWO- IN THAT IS SO SENATOR
NIELSEN. WELCOME CENTER NIELSEN.
PLEASE COME ON UP I THINK WE
HAVE A SANITIZED AREA FOR YOU
THERE AND YOU MAY PERCENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
VICE CHAIR. AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OVER THE COURSE OF
THIS LAST YEAR LONGER THAN THAT
NOW. I RATHER DOUBT IT EVER
OFFICES HAVE RECEIVED MORE
CALLS. COMPLAINTS AND FRANTIC
ENTREATIES FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS THEN THE SITUATION
AT THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. HAVING DEALT WITH
THIS DEPARTMENT FOR MANY MANY
YEARS I WOULD NOTE THAT IT IS A
TROUBLED DEPARTMENT AND LONG
HAS BEEN. I WOULD FURTHER NOTE
THAT THERE ARE SOME VERY GOOD
LOYAL HARD WORKING PEOPLE
WITHIN THAT DEPARTMENT. SHOULD
SHARE THEIR JOBS AND DOING THE
BEST THEY CAN. BUT I WILL HAVE
TO SAY THAT OF LATE. WE WITH
THE PANDEMIC. THEY'VE BEEN A
MISERABLE AND GRIEVOUS FATAL
FAILURE. THE CALLS THE HELP
COMMAND BESIEGE OUR OFFICERS
SHOULD. WITH INSTRUCTIVE IN
GETTING REPORTS FROM MY OWN
TEAM MYSELF. PEOPLE WOULD CALL
IN. AND HAVE A HUMAN VOICE
ANSWERED THE PHONE AND BEGIN
WEEPING. LEAPING BECAUSE THEY
REACHED THE HUMAN VOICE.
INSTEAD OF NOT HAVING ANY
ACCESS BY MANY MEANS THAT
OTHERS HAVE TRIED. IT DIDN'T
WORK. MANY WERE IN JEOPARDY OF.
LOSING THEIR APARTMENTS. NOT
HAVING ANY FOOD. THIS IS
UTTERLY AND ABSOLUTELY
INEXCUSABLE. IN THE STATE.
IRONICALLY EVEN WELL INTO THIS
DISASTER. THE DEPARTMNT.
EXPERIENCE TO. TECHNOLOGY
FAILURES. CRASHED THERE SYSTEMS
CRASH. FURTHER COMPLICATING
THEIR INABILITY. TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. I BELIEVE
THERE'S NO MORE IMPORTANT ISSUE
BEFORE US TODAY MAYBE THAN
OTHER THAN CORONAVIRUS. IN THIS
ONE TO DEAL WITH ON BEHALF OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS. THE AUDITOR'S
DEPARTMENT DID A VERY THOROUGH
REVIEW AND INVESTIGATION. OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES. ENTER
PROFFERED REPORTS TO THIS
HONORABLE BODY- WHICH I HAVE
HERE. THERE WAS A WRITTEN
REPORT AS WELL. IN A NOTE
RELATED TO THESE. PORCH BUT THE
STATE AUDITOR AND OR- THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. VERY OFTEN
WE MEMBERS IN OUR BUSINESS
DON'T PAY ANY ATTENTION TO
THESE REPORTS. I SUBMIT THAT WE
CERTAINLY OUGHT TO. I TRY TO
DISCIPLINE MYSELF AND NOW I'M
NOT SAYING THAT I'M VERY GOOD
AT IT EITHER. THEY DO STACK UP
BUT THIS ONE. CANNOT BE IGNORED.
THEY HAVE DEFINED WHAT THEY
HAVE DEVELOPED DEPARTMENT TO
BEAT THE GREAT SUPPOSED TO
GREGIS UNNECESSARY PROBLEMS TO
ADDRESS FOURTH WITH. WITHIN
THIS DEPARTMENT. AND I BELIEVE
THAT IT'S INCUMBENT SINCE WE
HAVE NOT SEEN ANY EFFORTS MUCH
PUT FORTH BY ATV. RIGHT NOW
IT'S OUR JOB. THE LEGISLATURE
TO RESPOND WITH THE MANAGERS
LONG TERM SYSTEMIC DANCERS IN
CHANGING HOW THE WHOLE
OPERATION CONDUCTS ITS BUSINESS.
THE ORDER DID LOOK AT THE
PLEASURE OF ITEMS WITHIN THEIR-
PURVIEW AND HOW THEY DID THEIR
JOBS. AND THEY HIGHLIGHTED A
NUMBER OF. THIS BILL EXPRESSLY
RECITES. MAJOR FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE AUDITOR.
PLEASE DIDN'T COME FROM A FAR I
DIDN'T THINK THESE UP MYSELF.
I'VE BEEN AWARE OF THEM FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. BUT IN
FORMULATING AND PRESENTING THE
BILL TO YOU. THESE ARE FROM THE
ORDER. AND ONE OF OUR
COMMENTATORS AND I'M CALLING
HIM A COMMENTATOR MISTER BOB
HARRIS TODAY WILL BE ON THE
LINE. THE AUDITOR DOES NOT MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL NOT BE
BEFORE OR OPPOSED TO. BUT WILL
OFFER REASONS RATIONALE FOR
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS. I
SUFFICE TO SAY THAT I THINK
THAT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THEY ARE CERTAINLY. UNBIASED
BODY AND I'VE ENJOYED WORKING
WITH THEM AND FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND MANY MANY ISSUES.
QUICKLY TO ROLL OVER THIS I
DON'T KNOW. A COMPLETE OVERHAUL
OF THE I. T. SYSTEM IS VITAL.
THE NURSES ONE FOLKS WE HAVE
GOT TO GET RIGHT OVER DECADES
THIS STATE THE HIGH TECH
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD HAS SELDOM
IF EVER. GOTTEN ANY MAJOR
BILLION DOLLAR HIGH TECH
PROJECTS RIGHT. THE BILL OVER
BUDGET NOT ON TIME. WE CANNOT
DO THAT HERE. THE CALL CENTER
OPERATIONS ALSO BEEN A
MISERABLE FAILURE. AND THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED THERE.
TO AND THEN INSISTING THEY HAVE
TRAINED STAFF AVAILABLE TO
MANAGE CALL STATIONS ONE OF THE
IRONIES I GUESS I SHOULD
MISSTATED THE DIDN'T PROPOSE
ANYTHING WELL YEAH. HE DID THEY
TOOK PEOPLE FROM OTHER AGENCIES
HAVE ASSIGNED THEM THE EIGHTY
D. AND THAT TOOK THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE DOING THESE PROBLEM
SOLVING JOBS HELPING OUR
CONSTITUENTS AWAY FROM THEIR
JOBS. THAT IS SIGNED INTO THE
TRAINERS. THAT DEFIES LOGIC HOW
THAT MAKES ANY SENSE OR HOW
THAT HELPS. PEOPLE SO TRAINED
STAFF WILL BE VITAL. THERE WILL
ALSO NEED TO BE A WHOLE
OVERHAUL OF HOW THIS AGENCY.
DEALS WITH OR RATHER DOES NOT
DEAL WITH FRAUD. I NOTED THERE
EIGHT DIFFERENT LITTLE
DIVISIONS OR DEPARTMENTS.
WITHIN EIGHTY NOW THAT HAVE
SOME RESPONSIBILITY FOR FRAUD.
WELL IT SEEMS LIKE NOBODY HAS
BEEN ON DUTY. BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A HUGE BILLION DOLLAR
PROBLEM WITH FRAUD COULD
CONTEND WITH. SEOUL TIME
ADVOCATING A SINGLE UNIT THERE
IN. IN CHARGE OF RESPONSIBLE
FOR AND ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PEOPLE. UNDER THE GOVERNOR
ENTER THE LEGISLATURE FOR
ENSURING THOSE FRAUD NUMBERS
REMAIN. NOT REMAIN BELOW ARE
COMPLETELY ELIMINATED ALTHOUGH
I WOULD NOT DARE HOPE THAT
WOULD BE THE CASE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN I KNOW WE CAN DO
BETTER AND CONSOLIDATION AND
ONE UNIT FOCUSED ON AN
ACCOUNTABLE AND RESPONSIBLE I
THINK WILL HELP. FURTHER THIS
IS NOT BEYOND THE CAPABILITY.
SHUTTING FOR CONTINGENCIES FOR
SUCH EVENTUALITIES RECESSIONS.
THEY DO HAPPEN. WE HAVE THE
WORLD'S OF ECONOMIST. THOUSANDS
OF HISTORY BOOKS WHICH WE CAN
REVIEW OF THE PREDICTABILITY OF
RECESSIONS. AND EVEN DEPRESSION.
THEY WILL HAPPEN AND WE ARE
SAYING NOW AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THIS AGENCY HAS. GATHER
INFORMATION FROM THOSE KNOWING
ENTITIES. THE PROJECT AND THEN
MORE IMPORTANTLY OR EQUALLY
IMPORTANTLY TO PREPARE FOR
THOSE EVENTUALITIES IN THIS
CASE NOTHING. NO PREPARATION
FOR ANY EMERGENCY SITUATION
AND- THEN THAT WE WOULD REQUIRE
THEM. AND THIS IS ONE OF MY
LEAST. IMPORTANT
RECOMMENDATIONS REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. NOW WHY WOULD I
SAY THAT'S MY LEAST. BECAUSE
THEY DON'T EVER TAKE THOSE
REPORTS SERIOUSLY. AND TO SELL
THEM AS I SAID ON THE BEGAN
THIS DISCUSSION NEWLY. A
REPORT. IS WONDERFUL IF IT'S
USED BUT MOST ARE NOT. THE
CLOSING I WOULD SUBMIT. THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF OUR WATER.
AND A GOOD STAFF. ARE ON POINT.
THERE'S NOTHING DREAMY THIS
ABOUT THIS AT ALL. THE COGENT
WELL SUPPORTED AND I AM
UNEQUIVOCALLY STATE THEY WILL
BE SUCCESSFUL. THEY MUST ALL BE
THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO PURSUE
THIS IN A STATUTORY WAY RATHER
THAN REGULATION. OR DEPARTMENT
OPERATION MANUAL. THIS HAS GOT
TO BE STATUTORY FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. WHERE THE COURSE
THE SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE GOVERNOR. MISTER BOB
CHERISH IS HERE WITH US WITH
YOUR INDULGENCE MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS IF YOU COULD
COMMENT. AND THEN WE WOULD HAVE
SOME OTHER WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT MISTER BOB CHERISH
THIS YEAR. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR ROOM MISTER HARRIS. YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BOB HARRIS FOR THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE I WAS A
PROJECT MANAGER ON OUR TWO MOST
RECENT AUDITS OF THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT- AS A
MATTER OF POLICY WE DON'T TAKE
A FORMAL POSITION ON BILLS BUT
ALL PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH
AN OVERVIEW OF THE WAYS THAT SB
TWO THIRTY TWO ADDRESSES KEY
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD COMING OUT
OF THOSE AUDITS AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE RELATED
TO THEM. IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME- JUST HIGHLIGHT TWO AREAS
OF THE BILL AND THEN TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
HAVE THE FIRST IS IN THE AREA
OF RECESSION PLANNING WE FOUND
THAT AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC ET DE DID NOT HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE RECESSION PLAN IN
OTHER WORDS IT HAD NO
COMPREHENSIVE PREPAREDNESS FOR
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN- IF AN
ECONOMIC RECESSION OCCURRED AS
WE KNOW. DEMAND FOR EDIE'S-
NEEDED ASSISTANCE INCREASES IN
TIMES OF RECESSION SO- BE GIVEN
THE REGULAR NATURE OF THOSE
RECESSIONS GIVEN SOME OF THE
PAST HISTORY EDT- STRUGGLES
THAT EDS HAD IN THE PAST
RESPONDING EFFECTIVELY TO
INCREASES IN DEMAND WERE
RECOMMENDING THAT THEY BE
REQUIRED TO PREPARE
COMPREHENSIVELY FOR WHAT TO DO
IN THE EVENT A RECESSION CAUSES
AN INCREASE IN DEMAND. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO DO
SO THE SECONDARY ALL COVER AND
THEN TAKE QUESTIONS IN THE AREA
OF. FRAUD ANALYSIS ESSENTIALLY
KNOWING FOR CERTAIN THAT THE
FRAUD PREVENTION TECHNIQUES EDT
USERS ARE ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE AT
PREVENTING FRAUD THEY HAD NO
SUCH ASSESSMENT WHEN WE
CONDUCTED OUR AUDITS WE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THEM TO DO
REGULAR FRAUD EFFECT FRAUD
PREVENTION EFFECTIVENESS
ASSESSMENTS IN A IN OTHER WORDS
THEY SHOULD KNOW WHETHER
THEY'RE STOPPING AS MUCH FRAUD
AS POSSIBLE AND ALSO NOT UNDULY
DELAYING LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS
FROM RECEIVING THEIR BENEFITS
BY USING. AN EFFECTIVE FRAUD
PREVENTION TECHNIQUE. AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED DIRECTLY TO EDT
THAT THEY CONSOLIDATE THEIR
FRAUD PREVENTION OPERATIONS
INTO A SINGLE UNIT DOING SO
WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH FRAUD
PREVENTION BEST PRACTICES I
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO CENTRALLY
ON OPERATOR FROM. PREVENT
OPERATIONS AND WITH THAT I'LL
TAKE ANY OF THE QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE I HAVE. THANK YOU OF
THE SERVICE WE'RE GONNA PROCEED
TO TAKE- SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- IN FRONT TIME ALLOWS
FOR YOU YOU WANT TO STAND BY
THERE MAY BE QUESTIONS WE BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND- I
JUST REMIND US. THAT WE THIS
COMMITTEE DID A PARTICIPATING
THE FULL INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON ON THE AUDIT THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO EARLIER IN THE
YEAR- BUT THERE- OF COURSE
MAYBE SOME QUESTIONS ON YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. THANK YOU WILL
MOVE. BACK TO THE ROOM HERE AND
ASK THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMUNITY ROOM THAT WAS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
THIRTY TWO- THE SCENE- WILL
MOVE TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM AND
ASKED IS ANYONE THERE WHO WAS
TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF TWO
THIRTY TO SEE NONE. GOOGLE THE
MODERATOR IN THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE AND I'M GONNA PAUSE
AGAIN AT A MODERATOR IF YOU
DON'T MIND. AND INDICATE THE
PARTICIPANT PHONE NUMBER. OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN ASKED O DO BY
THEIR- FOR IT FOLKS BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT APPEARING ON THE
SCREEN TODAY WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THE PUBLIC HAS EVERY.
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE TO
THE TELECOM SERVICE BY. CALLING
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX.
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. IN THE
ACCESS CODE. IS. FIVE ZERO ZERO
SIX THREE ZERO EIGHT. A REPEAT
THAT AGAIN LATER. ON THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON THIS BILL TWO
THIRTY TWO. AN INDICATOR OF HOW
MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO THIRTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
TWO LINES IN THE QUEUE THE
MOMENT FOR THE LINE NUMBERS TO
BE PROVIDED. NINE ONE ZERO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO EVERYBODY-
EMVCO CARLTON I WENT THROUGH
SIX MONTHS. OF KNOWING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS DURING
THE START UP DEPENDENTLY
BECAUSE OF EDT FOR INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS. COUNTLESS CALLS
EMAILS AND EMAILS. YOUR
RESPONSES NOT UNTIL SEVEN
THIRTY NIELSEN OFFICERS HELPED
ME REACH OUT TO EDT MY SIMPLE
NAME CHANGE SITUATION HAS BEEN
RESOLVED. I SUPPORT SENATOR
NIELSEN PROPOSAL THAT WE CAN BE
READY FOR THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
LET ME- THANK YOU LET ME REMIND
IN THE US THE MODERATOR TO HELP
ENFORCE HUNDRED THIS PORTIONS
TOLD CONFERENCE PORTION OF
TESTIMONY AS WELL AS ANYBODY
WHO'S NOT ONLY WITNESS PROTESTS
OPPOSING PERSON YOU ARE
RESTRICTED TO INDICATING YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION. AND
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
REMINDING ABOUT THAT EARLIER WE
CAN NOW PROCEED THE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LINE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SONNY CREWS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU. LOOK NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU-
REPEAT THAT PROCESS OF THE
SPEAKER THE TERMS OF
OPPOSITION- THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS INDICATED ON
THE BILL I WILL ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHO ISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO THIRTY TWO
OPAL CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM-
THERE'S NOT ANYONE THERE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY HASSANAL IN
PERSON OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL COME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR- IN S. MODERATORS. TO
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS AGAIN LIMITED TO NAME
AFILIATION. EXEMPT OPPOSITION
POSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU MR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SP TWO THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
NE. AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO THIRTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND- SEE IF
THERE'S SO IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL- SENATOR RUSSELL. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S SERVE QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR OR FOR MISTER
HARRIS- I HAVE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS BECAUSE- WE HAD THIS
HEARING. AND SO MUCH
INFORMATION WAS PROVIDED FOR US
AS MUCH AS COULD BE- ARE FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR- WE ALSO HAVE
THE GOVERNOR STRIKE TEAM
ANOTHER. ANOTHER SORT OF GROUP
TO EVALUATE AND JUDGE OF WHAT
HAPPENED. OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
LOT OF BIG PIECES CONNECTED TO
THIS THIS IS THE- PREPARING IT
WAS- PUT UP A PLAN TO BE PARRIS
FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND YET
AT THE SAME TIME ALL WHEN
THERE'S LITTLE USE OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THAT'S
WHEN WE HAVE THE LEAST
RESOURCES ON THERE SO TO
PREPARE FOR THAT ANYWAY THEY
WERE ALL THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF THE E. D. D. WHAT COULD OF
WHAT WENT WRONG WHAT WHAT COULD
WE DO ABOUT IT- I'M NOT SURE
HERE- WITH THE STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND NOW- THE
SENATOR'S PROPOSAL IS. HOW DO
WE COMPARE. HOW CAN WE FIGURE
OUT HERE WHAT'S BEING TAKEN UP
FROM ALL THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND WHAT'S BEEN LEFT OUT. ON
IT'S KIND OF LIKE A PUZZLE
EVERYTHING HAS TO FIT IN AND
I'M CONCERNED THAT WERE SORT OF
PICKING AND CHOOSING PIECES OF
IT. BUT SOMETIMES THE PIECES
DON'T ALWAYS ADD UP TO THE FULL
PICTURE OF HOW WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD SO I'M JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PICK AND CHOOSE- FOR
THEIR ANY RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
EITHER THE STRIKE TEAM. OR THE
AUDIT THAT ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL WHICH ONES ARE THEY
WHY AREN'T THEY INCLUDED. ON
OUR THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN IN THE
AUDIT THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED
TODAY SO I JUST FEEL LIKE- I'M
NOT. SURE I HAVE THE FULL.
BENEFIT OF THE FULL PICTURE
HERE. THE IN ORDER FOR NAY I
WOULD LIKE TO DO FOR. SOURCE
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT I THINK
MISTER HARRIS CAN GIVE US A
BETTER ANSWER MAYBE THE NóI
THOSE WHO SERVICE IF YOU CAN IF
YOU WANT TO ATTEMPT A CONCISE
RESPONSE TO- SENATOR OFFICES-
EXCELLENT A POINT SCORING
NUMBER VARIAS PLEASE DO SO AND
THEN WE'LL TURN TO SENATOR
LAYERED FOR HIS COMMENTS THANK
YOU MR CHERRY YES SO- IF THERE
IS SOME OVERLAP THERE ARE SOME
AREAS WHERE THE STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY OUR
AUDIT DON'T DO NOT OVERLAP- ONE
OF THE PROVISIONS OF. THIS BILL
THAT WE SHARE WITH THE STRAIGHT
TEAM- IN TERMS OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS IS RELATED TO
THE I. T. SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION
PROJECT- THE SENATORS INCLUDED
IN HIS BILL ONE OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH IS THE
SAME AS THE GOVERNOR STRIKE
TEAM RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS
THE DEPARTMENT EDT NEEDS TO
START PRIORITIZING THE PARTS OF
THAT PROJECT THAT CAN BEST
SERVE CALIFORNIANS SO THE
GOVERNOR'S STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDED THAT THE PROJECT BE
PAUSED RECONSIDERED WE'VE SAID
AS YOU RECONSIDER PLEASE.
PRIORITIZE THE PARTS THAT CAN
BE DONE MOST QUICKLY AND THAT
CAN HELP CALIFORNIANS THE
SOONEST SO I THINK THERE'S SOME
GOOD OVERLAP BETWEEN US AND THE
GOVERNOR STRIKE TEAM THERE WITH
RESPECT TO OUR THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE THAT
ARE NOT IN THIS BILL YES THERE
ARE SOME- THIS BILL DOES
IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS.
VIRTUALLY VERBATIM AS THE
SENATOR SAID- AND SOME OF THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE ONCE OF THE
NEED FOR RECESSIONARY PLANNING-
AND IT'S PRECISELY BECAUSE-
THINGS ARE TIGHT THAT EDT NEEDS
TO KNOW HOW TO BEST MANAGE
LIMITED RESOURCES- WHEN
INCREASED DEMAND OCCURS- SAME
THING FOR FRAUD PREVENTION
EFFECTIVENESS- IT'S EATING
STAFF A COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOWALL THE
DIFFERENT THINGS IT DOES TO
PREVENT FRAUD ARE WORKING
TOGETHER. OR NOT WORKING
TOGETHER IDEALLY. THANK YOU.
HOME SOON DRAWS ON IT BEFORE
YOU SEE THE FOUR ONE MAKE SURE
YOU CHECK AND SEE. I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE AUTHORS. EFFORT
TO ADDRESS THIS ARE I WOULD
STILL SOMEHOW I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE MISTER CHAIR. HOW WE WOULD
GET THE COMPARISON SO WE COULD
SEE WHAT'S MISSING AND WHAT'S
BEING ADDRESSED I DON'T HAVE
THE IMPRESSION. THAT OKAY THIS
IS DEALING WITH EVERYTHING AND
THEN COME BACK AND SAY NO THEIR
THIS WAS MISSING THIS WAS
MISSING. FOR IT- THE BILL
CONTAINS THINGS THAT MAYBE
DON'T MAKE SENSE ARE COMPARED
TO THE OTHER PIECES SO IF
THERE'S ANY WAY THAT WE COULD.
I COULD GET THAT PROVIDED ALL
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR TODAY
I WOULD. I WOULD SUPPORT BUT-
I'M HOLDING ON TO SEE EXACTLY
WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE IN FOR
HERE. THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO.
DRAWS ARE THERE ARE MANY DEALS
AND MANY IDEAS WELL NOT AS MANY
AS I EXPECTED THERE MIGHT BE
BECAUSE OF THE ANGER OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS THE BUT THAT SAID.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOR THAT'S
OUR JOB THAT'S WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE DOES WE NEED AND WE
CONSIDER. FIVE SET TO THE LONG
EIGHTY HEARINGS AS WELL. AND
HEARD MANY IDEAS. ALL OF WHICH
I LISTEN TO NONE OF US ARE NOT
SOME OF WHICH I TOOK VERY
SERIOUSLY OTHERS I DID NOT. BUT
THAT'S OUR JOB AND THERE'S THE
BILL'S PROGRESS BILLS PLURAL.
THEN LEAVE THEM TO COLLECTIVELY
THE LEGISLATURE IN OUR
COMMITTEE STRUCTURES. THERE ARE
LEADERSHIP NEGOTIATIONS WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION IN SOME
CASES. WE WILL THEN AS WE
USUALLY DO COME UP WITH THE
FINAL SOLUTION. I EXPECT TO BE
MORE THAN ONE BILL. BUT I DO
NOT EXPECT ANYTHING WE DO. THIS
YEAR. MAY BE ENOUGH. THIS IS
TAKEN DECADES TO GET THIS
TANGLED UP AS IT HAS BEEN. BUT
MY POINT IS WE MUST ACT WE
OUGHT TO THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA ACT. EXPEDITIOUSLY
AND THAT WOULD MEAN BY THE END
OF THE SESSION. YOU SENATOR-
CENTER LAYERED THANK YOU TOM.
LET ME OFFER. A LITTLE LIGHT
OF. THE B. BECAUSE- I'M ON J.
LACK IN THE VICE CHAIR WE HAD A
HERE THERE WAS AN AUDIT. A AND-
THERE WERE AS I RECALL TWO
MAJOR RECOMMENDATIONS ACTUALLY
I DON'T THINK THIS BILL HAS THE
RECESSION PLANNING BECAUSE I'M
DOING THAT BILL IT IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL AND IT
BASICALLY SAYS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT CAME FROM
THE AUDITOR THAT WE WOULD PUT
THAT IN THE STATUTE. BECAUSE
THERE WAS THE GREAT RECESSION
AND A SIMILAR THING HAPPENED
TEN YEARS AGO WITH THE D. D.
THERE WAS AN AUDIT REPORT THAT
WAS VERY SIMILAR IT WAS NOT
IMPLEMENTED IT- THE MELTDOWN
NEGATIVE RECOMMENDATION CAME
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN IT WASNOT
IMPLEMENTED THEN THIS HAPPENED.
UNDER GOVERNOR KNOWS SOME. AND
WE DON'T TO FACE ANOTHER.
WITHOUT THERE EVER BEING A PLAN
THAT IS IN PLACE BEFORE HAND TO
SCALE UP WHEN THAT HAPPENS SO
WE DON'T HAVE WHAT HAPPENED
HERE. BUT HAVEN'T I WAS NOT
CONSIDERING THAT THERE MIGHT BE
THINGS IN THE STRIKE TEAM. ARE
THAT THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN IN
ADDITION TO THE AUDIT THAT
WOULD BE AN BILLS BECAUSE I
THINK. THE TWO MAJOR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
INCORPORATED BETWEEN THIS BILL
AND THE BILL ON TO WHEN.
THERE'S A STRIKE TEAM AND THE
PLACE THAT THERE RE A TON OF
BILLS ARE COMING OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY. BUT THEY HAVE DONE A
COMPLETE PACKAGE AND THEY
WEREN'T NECESSARILY THINGS THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN THE AUDIT TO
OUR- PEOPLE DID THEIR OWN
THINGS AND SO I THINK. TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO SENATOR DORADO
WHICH IS THE RIGHT QUESTION. IS
IF THERE MAJOR RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE STRIKE TEAM AND THEIR
STUFF MAJOR RECOMMENDATIONS OUT
OF THE AUDIT THEY OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO BE EASILY CROSS
REFERENCED WITH THE BILLS. TO
FIND OUT WHAT'S INCLUDED AND
WHAT'S MISSING I JUST KNOW THE
MAJOR ONES THAT WERE IN THE
AUDIT OR IN BILLS THAT ARE
MOVING I DON'T KNOW. ABOUT THE
STATUS OF THE- CONSTRUCTING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I KNOW THAT
SOME OF THE ASSEMBLY BILLS
AREN'T THINGS THAT WEREN'T IN
EITHER OF THE OTHER DAY ARE
REALLY TRYING TO STRIKE OUT.
AND DEAL WITH THAT SO I THINK.
THE FAIR QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
GET AN OVERALL LOOKS OF THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A BILL COME BY AND
WE TAKE ACTION PIECEMEAL WHICH
I THINK IS YOUR POINT AND IT IS
THE RIGHT POINT. AND IT'S
UNPREPARED TO VOTE FOR THIS
BILL. ARE BECAUSE OF WHAT IT
DOES IN RELATION THE AUDIT AND
I HAVE STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT DID NOT OPPOSITION. TO
THE BILL THAT DOES STUFF. THE A
RECESSION PLAN TO I THINK THE
QUESTION IS AND I DON'T KNOW
WHO DOES IT I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S- STAFF OF OUR COMMITTEE.
FOR PEOPLE IN GENERAL I CAN
HELP WITH THE ORDER COULD HELP
BUT IT JUST NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
AND MAYBE COMING OUT OF THIS WE
CAN MAKE SURE SO THAT BEFORE WE
SEE. THIS BILL AGAIN SOMEWHERE
OR ANOTHER BILL WE HAVE A
FLAVOR. FOR WHAT THAT SITUATION
IS THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED ANY OTHER COMMENTS THAT
APPEARED MEMBERS WOULD ARGUE
THAT. WE ARE WE CAN'T JUST
WALLOW IN EVERYTHING IS IN
PROCESS IT IS A PROCESS THAT
THE LEAD PROCESS. ONE BILL
DOESN'T HAVE TO DO IT ALL. I
DON'T EXPECT IT TO. AND THERE
WILL BE NEGOTIATIONS AS WE
PROCEED. THIS IS A POLICY
COMMITTEE ARE THESE POLICIES
SATISFACTORY TO THE COMMITTEE
WILL THEY HELP THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAVE THEY BEEN
OFFERED. BY A CREDIBLE SOURCE I
DO NOT THINK YOU COULD FIND A
MORE CREDIBLE SOURCE THEN WE
HAVE FOR THE PROVISIONS AREA.
AND WHATEVER BILL SHOULD COME
TOGETHER AS WE PROCEED. THAT'S
HOW WE WILL VOTE IN ACCORD WITH
WHAT IS BEFORE US AT THE TIME.
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS IN
FACT THAT. PEOPLE WORKING
PROCESS ARE WE DONE WITH THIS
BILL HEAVENS NO LONG WAY TO GO
BUT I WOULD ASK THE
INTELLIGENCE OF THE COMMITTEE
TO BROUGH TO SO LONG AS A SOUND
WELL THOUGHT OUT SUPPORTABLE
VESSEL. AS WE PROCEED IN
LEGISLATION TO HELP THE
CITIZENS WHO HAVE BEEN SO
AGGRIEVED MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED I DON'T THINK
THESE COMMENTS WERE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE IT'S I THINK PEOPLE
ARE WILLING TO MOVE YOUR BILL
LONG BECAUSE- FOR WHAT IT IS IT
IS GOOD AND IT MEETS A
RECOMMENDATION BUT IT IS A
REALLY FAIR QUESTION TO SEE HOW
THE WHOLE THING FITS TOGETHER.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
DOING THINGS THAT DON'T FIT
TOGETHER SO IT'S LIKE I'M GOING
TO VOTE AT THE RIGHT TIME TO
MOVE THE BILL BY REALLY SUPPORT
WHAT CENTER DRAWS SO SAID SO
THAT WE HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT'S
THERE ACROSS THE BOARD AND
MAKING SURE THAT. IT THAT IT
ISN'T THE GOVERNOR FIGURING IT
OUT BY WHAT ORDER HE SIGNS BILL
SAID TO CHAPTER OUT THINGS THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ASKING US.
QUESTIONS AS THE BILLS CAME BY.
THE CENTER LANE. I DO- HAVE
SOME COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS-
SOME OF THE MAJOR ISSUES IN THE
EDT INCLUDED OUTDATED AND
ARCHAIC TECHNOLOGY AND
TECHNOLOGY UPGRADE
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES PROBLEMS
WITH CLAIMS PROCESSING AND THE
DELIVERY OF BENEFITS PROBLEMS
WITH RESPONDING TO CUSTOMER
ENQUIRIES AND ASSISTING
CUSTOMERS WITH CLAIMS AND
PROBLEMS WITH FRAUD DETECTION
AND PREVENTION. AS I UNDERSTAND
HAD THE PROVISIONS IN SB TWO
THIRTY TO COME DRECTLY FROM
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE RECENT
STATE AUDIT REPORT ON THE ED'S
FAILURES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
GIVING YOUR EXPERTISE- AND
FAMILIARITY WITH THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS CAN YOU BRIEFLY
WALK ME THROUGH- THE MAJOR
PROVISIONS THE PROBLEM THEY ARE
INTENDED TO ADDRESS. AND HOW DO
YOU ENVISION THEM ADDRESSING
THE PROBLEM. YES MANAGER SO THE
MAJOR PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
START WITH THE WHAT I MENTIONED
BEFORE WHICH IS THE BENEFITS
SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION PROJECT
TO CD'S LONGSTANDING
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PRODUCTS
TO PROJECTS TO MODERNIZE ITS
SYSTEMS SO THAT THEY'RE MORE
CUSTOMER FRIENDLY. AND THAT
THEY WORK MORE EFFECTIVELY FOR
EDT THE PROJECT HAS BEEN IN
PROCESS FOR A LONG TIME- AND
WASN'T SCHEDULED TO BE
COMPLETED UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR- AS I MENTIONED A MOMENT
AGO THE GOVERNOR STRIKE TEAM
RECOGNIZED THAT THE SYSTEM-
MODERNIZATION PROJECT NEEDED TO
BE PAUSED AND RESTOCKED. WE
AGREE WITH THAT RECOMMENDATION
WE MADE A RECOMMENDATION TO EDT
THAT THEY RETHINK THE PROJECT
WITH A PRIORITY ON THE
COMPONENT PARTS OF IT THAT
WOULD BE MOST HELPFUL TO
CALIFORNIANS AND THE QUICKEST
AMOUNT OF TIME IN THIS BILL.
IMPLEMENTS THAT RECOMMENDATION
BY REQUIRING EDT TO PRIORITIZE
THOSE ELEMENTS OF THE SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT. THE NEXT
MAJOR AREA OF THE BILL IS THE
CALL CENTER OPERATIONS IT ASKS
EDT TO HAVE BETTER DATA ABOUT
WHY PEOPLE ARE CALLING FOR
ASSISTANCE SO THAT THEY CAN BE
SERVED THROUGH NON CALL CENTER-
AVENUES SO THAT THEY CAN
RECEIVE THE ASSISTANCE THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR. TO GET
THEIR BENEFITS MORE TIMELY
WITHOUT HAVING TO WAIT ON HOLD
OR AND NOT ACTUALLY EVEN GET
THROUGH TO A CALL CENTER AGENT.
SAID THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE EDT
TO UNDERTAKE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION COLLECTION.
ASSESSMENT AND IN RESPONSE TO
THAT ASSESSMENT. IN CHANGES TO
ITS OPERATIONS TO BETTER SERVE
THOSE WERE LOOKING FOR HELP.
FOUR AUTHORED AT RECOMMENDING
IN THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE EDT
TO TRACK FIRST CALL RESOLUTION
WHICH IS- MET AN INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICE METRIC WHICH WOULD-
TELL EDT WHETHER IT'S
SUCCESSFULLY ASSISTING PEOPLE
THE FIRST TIME TO CALL FOR
ASSISTANCE. SO THAT'S AN
INDUSTRY STANDARD PRACTICE OF
HOW WELL YOUR CALL CENTER
OPERATES IF SOMEONE HAS TO CALL
YOU MORE THAN ONCE THEN THAT'S-
SOMETHING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAVE TO LEARN FROM BUT RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE NOT TRACKING NOT AT
ALL. SO THEY NEED TO START
TRACKING AND MONITORING WHETHER
THEY'RE SUCCESSFULLY ASSISTING.
CLAIMANTS WHO CALLED THE FIRST
TIME I CALL. THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO DO SO. THE BILL
THEN REQUIRES EDT TO DEVELOP A
RECESSION PLAN- IN LINE WITH
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE LESSONS LEARNED DURING
THE PANDEMIC PERIOD BUT ALSO
PAST RECESSIONS. AS I MENTIONED
IN MY TESTIMONY EARLIER TO BE
BETTER PREPARED FOR THE
INCREASED DEMAND FOR THAT
TIMELY ASSISTANCE THAT PEOPLE
NEED. WHICH HAPPENS WHEN A
RECESSION OCCURS. THEY SHOULD
ALSO UPDATE THAT PLAN REGULARLY
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO DO. FINAL AREA
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO
TAKE ACTION ON IS IN THE AREA
FRAUD PREVENTION. AS I
MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY THEY
HAD NO ASSESSMENT OF HOW
EFFECTIVELY THEY ARE PREVENTING
FRAUD WE NEED A COMPREHENSIVE
LOOK. TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE
COMPONENT THINGS THAT THEY DO
TO TRY AND PREVENT FRAUD. ARE
BOTH ON THEIR OWN EFFECTIVE OR
NOT. AND THAT THEY'RE WORKING
WELL TOGETHER OR NOT. I NEED TO
COMPILE THAT ASSESSMENT
PROVIDED TO LEGISLATURE REFRESH
ANNUALLY- REGULARLY. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THEM TO DO FINALLY AS I
MENTIONED THEY ALSO NEED TO
CONSOLIDATE. THEIR FRAUD
PREVENTION APPROACH INTO A
SINGLE UNIT THAT'S WHAT. FRAUD
PREVENTION BEST PRACTICES
RECOMMEND IT'S NOT WHAT WE SAW
WHEN WE DID THE AUDIT THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO ADOPT OUR
RECOMMENDATION. PERFECT THIRD
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION.
PURPOSES THIS BILL. RECESSION
PLANNING AREA. AND TO BE FRIED-
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE FRAUD
PREVENTION APPROACH THERE'S A
QUITE FOUNDATIONAL AREAS- THE
EDT NEEDS TO MAKE ADVANCES ON.
THAT COMPREHENSIVE RECESSION
PLAN WILL ALLOW EDG TO KNOW.
THAT WHEN DEMAND STARTS TO
INCREASE FOR ITS ASSISTANCE.
HOW IT'S GOING TO RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY SO IT DOESN'T. NEED
TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS IN A IN
A SORT OF EMERGENCY MOMENT-
IT'LL BE PREPARED IF IT DOES
SUCH A PLAN. TO KNOW HOW'S IT
GOING TO QUICKLY SCALE IT STAFF
UP. WHAT AREAS OF ITS
OPERATIONS CAN TEMPORARILY
SCALED BACK AND NOT EXPERIENCE
ANY NEGATIVE EFFECTS. SO THOSE
ARE PRETTY IMPORTANT PLANNING
STEPS THAT THEY NEED TO
UNDERTAKE AND SPECIFICALLY TO
ADDRESS. WEAKNESSES THAT THEY
KNOW THEY HALF THAT THEY'VE
HEARD ABOUT FOR YEARS NOW. IN
IN THE FRAUD PREVENTION
EFFECTIVENESS. RIGHT NOW HE
DOESN'T KNOW IF IT'S USING AN
EFFECTIVE TOOLS TO PREVENT
FRAUD. SO IT NEEDS TO KNOW
WHETHER IT COULD BE ALLOWING US
WE SAW SOME FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
TO PASS THROUGH AND GET PAID-
HOW CAN IT FINE TUNE ITS TOOLS
TO PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE. AND THEN
FINALLY. IS IT PREVENTING
UNDULY LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS BY
CATCHING THEM IN A FRAUD
PREVENTION TOOL THAT'S NOT
ACTUALLY VERY EFFECTIVE AT
DETECTING FRAUD INSTEAD IT'S- A
SITE TRACKING LEGITIMATE
CLAIMANTS. TO DOING THAT
ANALYSIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF THE
TWO PRETTY FOUNDATIONAL
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL.
WONDERFUL S. THIS BILL HAS A
NUMBER OF IMPLEMENTATION DATES
THAT ARE OVER A YEAR FROM NOW
IN YOUR VIEW. ARE THESE STATE
APPROPRIATE. AND WHAT WOULD BE
YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ENSURING THAT EDT ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTS THESE
pCERTAINLY WITHIN THE SPIRIT OF
WHAT WE SAID WE PUT DEADLINES
ON OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AS WELL-
AND SOME OF THESE ARE FURTHER
OUT THAN THE RECOMMENDED DATES
THAT WE SET BUT CERTAINLY THE
BILLS WELL WITHIN THE SPIRIT OF
WHAT WE SAID WHICH IS THAT
THERE SHOULD BE DATE CERTAIN-
THAT BY WHICH EDT SHOULD BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HAVING
COMPLETED THE ACTIONS. AND. AND
THE ISSUE OF ENSURING THAT EDT
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTS THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT- SO FOR THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE BILL
ADOPTS THAT WE HAVE ALSO MADE
DIRECTLY TO EDT OUR OFFICE DES
A FOLLOW UP AND REPORT PUBLICLY
ENSURES INFORMATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE PROGRESS
THE DEPARTMENT MAKES IN
IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'VE MADE
DIRECTLY TO EDT AND THE BILL
DOES TAKE SOME OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WOOD. IF
PASSED INTO LAW AS IS HE WOULD
GRADUATE THEM TO STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS NOT JUST
RECOMMENDATIONS WE'VE MADE TO
THE DEPARTMENT BUT EVEN SO WILL
STILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH THE V. D. TO SEE WHAT
THEY'VE DONE TO ADDRESS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE
DIRECTLY TO THEM WITH RESPECT
TO SOME OF THE PARTS OF THE
BILL. THEY ARE RECOMMENDATIONS
WE NEED TO THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTLY BECAUSE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THEM BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THE HISTORY WITH EDT WE
FELT THEY NEEDED TO BE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS FROM
THEN- WE WOULD OPINE ABOUT
WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE TOOK
THE ACTIONS WE RECOMMENDED- AND
MAKE OURSELVES AVAILABLE FOR-
FOLLOW UP REVIEW. OKAY IN A
MINUTE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
FACT THAT YOU'RE HEARING YOU'RE
THE EXPERT- GIVEN THAT THESE
ISSUES WERE KNOWN. WHY IN YOUR
VIEW DIDN'T EDTA TRUSTEES
ISSUES IN THE INTERVENING YEARS
BETWEEN THE GREAT RECESSION AND
THE OFFICE OF COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE EIGHTY CONTENDS
THAT IT DID TAKE ACTION IN THE
YEARS BETWEEN THE RECESSION AND
THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC- IT
DID TAKE SOME ACTIONS TO
MODERNIZE ITS PROCESSES FOR
INSTANCE YOU CAN NOW APPLY FOR
BENEFITS ONLINE. OUR POSITION
IS THAT THOSE CHANGES TO ITS
OPERATIONS WERE NOT SUFFICIENT
ENOUGH EVEN IN THE MONTHS
LEADING UP TO THE PANDEMIC
EDIE'S PERFORMANCE WAS
SUBSTANTIVELY SIMILAR TO IT'S-
PAST PER FOR PERFORMANCE. SO
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH EDT TOOK NO
ACTION IT JUST DIDN'T TAKE
SUFFICIENT ACTION TO ADDRESS
ITS PERFORMANCE- AND THAT
ULTIMATELY ENDED UP. HINDERING
IT FROM EFFECTIVELY SERVING
CALIFORNIANS DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE ACKNOWLEDGE. IN THE
AUDIT IT'S MULTIPLE TIMES THAT
THE SCOPE SPAN AND SPEED OF THE
PANDEMIC RECESSION WAS
COMPLETELY UNPRECEDENTED. SO
NOTHING THEY DID WAS GOING TO
PREPARE THEM FULLY FOR THE
PANDEMIC RECESSION. AT THE
COULD HAVE BEEN MORE PREPARED
THAN THEY WERE. PERFECT AND-
RIGHT NOW COULD YOU PROVIDE US
AN UPDATE ON THE CURRENT
PROGRESS- BASED ON THE EDT
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS UP
TO THIS POINT NOT AT THIS TIME
EDIE'S FIRST RESPONSE BACK TO
US ABOUT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
DUE THIS WEEK SO WILL RECEIVE
IT THIS WEEK TO A FAST
ASSESSMENT NOW WE'LL GET
COMMITTEE THAT INFORMATION.
WONDERFUL PERFECT DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY I DO HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL. SENATOR LAYERED HAS
MOVED TO THE- S. B. TWO THIRTY
TWO. THANK YOU CENTER BILL- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON IS
THAT APPROPRIATIONS. S. SALTON
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
COURTESY. SENATOR UNTIL SORRY I
FORGOT TO ASK SENATOR NIELSEN
TO CLOSE I AM SO SORRY MY
APOLOGIES SENATOR NIELSEN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD JUST
SHORTEN IT VERY MUCH I THANK
THE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
INDULGENCE TODAY OTHER AT FIRST
I THINK IT IS MANIFEST. AS MARK.
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
FROM MISTER HARRIS TODAY THEY
ACHIEVE WHAT I'D HOPED JUSTICE
IN LIKENESS AS TO WHAT THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS MORE ON THAT
AND THERE ARE AGENTS I WILL
REITERATE WHAT I HAD BEFORE
WHICH HE IS THIS IS A- ENDEMIC.
HERE'S DECADES LONG BUILDING UP
OF A PROBLEM. AND GETTING BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN OUR
PROCESS. IT IS ON US. AND ONE
GOOD THING THAT I'VE NOTED IN
THE SENATE. AFTER I RETURNED
MANY YEARS ABSENT. THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE I TAKING A
MUCH GREATER ROLE IN OVERSIGHT
OF AGENCIES THAT HISTORICALLY
SELL. IN OUR SUBCOMMITTEE XIN
OUR FULL COMMITTEE. AND THAT'S
BEEN LACKING TO A DEGREE. AND
NOW WE THE INDIVIDUAL
LEGISLATORS COULD GATHER MORE
INFORMATION BE MORE IN TOUCH
AND HAVE MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVENESS HOLDING AGENCIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING THE JOB
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS I THANK THIS
COMMITTEE FIRST TIME
INTELLIGENCE AND CONSIDERATION
I ASKED AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
CORTEZ IF. SENATOR CHAU BUG HI
AND- CHAU POKE HI SENATOR ALSO
SENATORS SO HI SENATOR LAYERED.
UNDER LAYERED HI SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN I. THANK YOU
MA'AM. CAN YOU CENTER ALSO WILL
HOLD THE CALL THE ROLL OPEN AT
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THAT WORK
FOR YOU. FOUR FOUR ZERO FIVE
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO. SENATOR ROB SPELLS SB SEVEN
FIVE FIVE. SENATE ROTH ARE YOU
READY THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR- MEMBERS. CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD IS
REQUIRED TO CONDUCT AN
EVALUATION OF WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS FUNDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT IN THE
STATE PROVIDES THE BOARD WITH
REQUIRED WAGE AND EMPLOYMENT
DATA TO EVALUATE THE EFFICACY
OF THESE PROGRAMS. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE FRANKLY IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT INDIVIDUALS AND
ROLE IN TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR
THE WORK FORCE SYSTEM HAVE
ACCESS TO A REASONABLE AND
OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS OF THE
RELATIVE SUCCESS OF TRAINING
PROGRAMS BEFORE THEY ENROLL.
AND WE SHOULD KNOW THAT
INFORMATION TO. IN OTHER WORDS
WHAT ARE YOU TRAINING TO DO. IS
THERE A JOB FOR YOU IN THAT
FIELD WHEN YOU FINISH. CHEN
WILL YOU MAKE OR EARN A LIVING
WAGE OR BETTER IF YOU TAKE IT.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE MEANS TO
DEVELOP THE SYSTEM SYSTEMATIC
MEASUREMENT OF TRAINING PROGRAM
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES. WITH
RESPECT TO THE FOLLOWING. THE
LIKELIHOOD OF EMPLOYMENT IN THE
OCCUPATIONS FOR WHICH PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS TRAIN. THE
LIKELIHOOD OF EMPLOYMENT IN
LIVING WAGE JOBS IN THE
RELEVANT REGIONAL LABOR MARKET.
AND THE PROSPECTS FOR WAGE GAIN
OVER TIME THE SO SEATED WITH
THESE PROGRAMS. THIS BILL
PROVIDES PROSPECTIVE TRAINING
PARTICIPANTS WITH INFORMATION
ON THE RELATIVE SUCCESS OF THE
VARIOUS TRAINING PROGRAMS
OFFERED THROUGH THE WORK FORCE
SYSTEM. THE PERPETRATOR I'M I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
RIVALS. THANK YOU SENATOR RALPH
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WANTED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD SUPPORT
WITH THIS IS THAT CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT MEMBERSHIP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
OFTEN WE WILL NOW MOVE OUT TO
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FIVE FIVE. HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OR FORTY TWO OR
THREE I'M SORRY SEEN NONE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN TWENTY
FORTY. IN SUPPORT OF S. FIVE
FIVE C. NINE. WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WANTING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCES. MODERATE
MATAMATA TRADER IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE FRONT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. FIVE FIVE WE WILL BE
AN- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MATTER NOT MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF. PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MATTER MATTER
MARK MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CHECK LINES ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF OUR
SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR. SB FIVE
FIVE. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN FIFTY
FIVE OR FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE. A
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE WELL WE
GATHER THE LINE NUMBER.
NINE
ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS NOEL BALAGUER ON MY
BEDROOM. AND I'VE BEEN ON AND
OFF OF THE PARTICIPANTS IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES HERE'S OUR
COMMUNITY. AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF. STATE FUNDING FOR NON
DEFENSE. IT'S BEEN A VERY. VERY
BIG SO MANY AND I ENJOYED IT
AND I CAN'T SAY ANYTHING MORE
THAN I JUST HOPE THAT PEOPLE
FOR IT- BUT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL OUR
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES AND
LINE IS THAT CORRECT SENATOR
OFF THAT'S CORRECT MEMBERSHIP.
THANK YOU SENATOR OFF WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE IN
OPPOSITION. CNN ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN FIVE FIVE. SEEN
NONE. THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATE MATTER MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB. SEVEN FIVE
FIVE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN FIVE FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD AT THE RIGHT TIME
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULDN'T MIND CHECKING THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL OUR OPPOSITION WITNESSES
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
pPRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR. THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT OF WELL WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OR WE
ACTUALLY HAVE ONE SUPPORT
WITNESS WE THANK YOU FOR
CALLING IN AND BEING. AND I'M
CALLING IN IN SUPPORT WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU MANUFACTURES SENATE ROTH-
HAVING BEEN INVOLVED IN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PRIOR TO
RUNNING VERTICALLY AROUND
VETERAN WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND HAVING SERVED AS THE
SENATE'S REP TO THE WORKFORCE
FROM FOURTH I WOULD SAY THAT
THIS IS. A VERY GOOD AND
SENSIBLE BILL I THANK YOU FOR
BRING IT FORWARD- WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL AND IF IT IS POSSIBLE AS A
MOVES FOR I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN.
ANYONE ELSE. I'M READY TO MOVE
THE BILL. IT'S A GREAT BILL BY
THE ONE YEAH. THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE- WE DO HAVE A
MOTION- FROM CENTER NEWMAN TO
MOVE THIS BILL. AND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH US SENATOR I'M SORRY
SENATOR- ROTH WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY AS FOR
NOT VOTE THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR CORTEZ EIGHT. CENTER
COURT AS THE HIGH CENTER A
CHOKE HI AND- CHAU FOLK HI
SENATOR TORONTO. SENATOR BLARED
BY SENATOR LAYERED HI SENATOR
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT ANOTHER NEWMAN
I. THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH WE
HAVE- FOR VOTES FOR ICE WILL
PUT THAT BILL ON CALL FOR AN
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE THANK YOU
WELL NOW PASSED A DOUBLE BACK
TO OUR KIDS. KAMALA BUTCHER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF THE NEXT TO THE
PRESENTATION WILL BE ON SB
EIGHT OH FIVE FOUR THIS IS
SENATOR RUBIO'S BILL. HI
ANDERSON THE AUTHORS ON OUR WAY
AND WE'RE GETTING THE- LUTEUM
READY FOR HER FIFTH.
WELCOME
CENTER RUBIO. YOU MAY BE BETTER
PRESENTED ON S. B. ZERO FIVE
WOULD HAVE PUT YOUR COME FROM
BEGINNING. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT THROUGH A LOT OF
HARD WORK AND COLLABORATION
THIS BILL REFLECTS THE WELL. OF
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO CAME
TO THE TABLE. I HAVE GOT IT THE
ORIGINAL BILL AND NOW TO BE
CLEAR THIS BILL IS NO LONGER AN
AB FIVE EXEMPTION. IT REFLECTS
THE GOAL OF THE ORIGINAL BILL
BUT ALSO TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION THE CONCERNS FROM
THE OPPOSITION. AS WELL AS MANY
IDEAS THAT WERE BROUGHT FORWARD.
THIS BILL DOES TWO CRITICAL
THINGS FIRST ESTABLISHES A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR SMALL
PERFORMING ARTS NONPROFIT.
ORGANIZATIONS THESE FUNDS ARE
MEANT TO HELP COMPLY WITH AB
FIVE. THE BILL CLEARLY SPELLS
OUT OF GRADUATION ANTHONY
LEVELS THE MORE THE NONPROFIT'S
MAKE THE LESS THEY QUALIFY FOR
AND RIGHTFULLY SO WE WANT TO
KEEP THE FOCUS ON THE SMALLEST
OF THEATERS. NEXUS BILL CREATED
ENTITY WITH STATE GOVERNMENT TO
HELP WITH PAYROLL PROCESSING
SERVICES THAT CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL. BY CREATING THIS THESE
NONPROFITS ARE ABLE TO GET DOWN.
ON OPERATIONS AND AN OVERHEAD
HELPING THEM SURVIVE. POLITICS
THIS ISSUE AS I'VE EXPRESSED
MANY OF YOU IS VERY PERSONAL TO
ME THIS IS NOT JUST THE BILL
BUT IT BECAME MY LIFE I GREW UP
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES WHERE
THERE WAS A LOT OF DRUGS. GANGS
AND VIOLENCE. EVERYWHERE YOU
SAW OUR FRIENDS FAMILIES GOT
PULLED INTO IT. I JUST HAPPENED
TO BE A VERY CREATIVE CHILD.
VERY ARTISTIC AND THE ART
BECAME MY A STATE. AND I WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE AROUND A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT EMBRACE THE ACT
ALL THE ENOUGH. I WAS AROUND
RIGHT BASS SAID O'NEILL SAID
ONO GODFATHER THERE ONCE- ONCE
STARTED TWENTY YEARS AGO. AND
WHAT I SAW. ON SAW THEM FIFTY
AND BRACE BILLS WITHOUT
EXPERIENCE. I THOUGHT HOW THEY
CREATED A SAFE PLACE FOR KIDS
ARGUES AND ACTORS TO. PRACTICE
AND REALLY HONE IN ON THE
SKILLS IT REALLY GIVE A VOICE
TO EVERYONE THEY WANTED TO GET
A START IN THIS FIELD. BUT IT'S
HARD NOT TO SEE THAT THIS ISSUE
IS NOT JUST ABOUT AXIS IN THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IT'S ABOUT SOCIAL JUSTICE AS
WELL. BERMAN ARTS HAVE BEEN A
POWERFUL TOOL FOR THE VOICELESS
HISTORICALLY MAJOR MOVEMENTS IN
OUR NATION'S HISTORY HAVE USED
PERFORMING ARTS TO ELEVATE
THEIR CALLS AND HELP SHAPE
POLICY. FROM THE WOMEN'S
SUFFRAGE MOVEMENT WHEN THEY
USED TO USE PLACE TO ENGAGE
AKRON WOMEN TO JOIN THE COST
AND HELP THEM FIGHT FOR
EQUALITY. TO BUT THERE WERE
RIGHTS MOVEMENT. THAT ERA WAS
REFERRED TO AS THE ERA OF
CREATIVE ACTIVISM THEY USE
IMAGERY POETRY SPOKEN WORD
ANYTHING MAKE IT USED TO
ELEVATE THEIR COSTS AND HELPED
SHAPE POLICY THAT WILL HELP
BETTER THEIR LIFE TO BE A BILL
CAMPESINO WHICH STARTED IN THE
FIELD FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WITH FARMWORKERS THESE ARE
FOLKS FIGHTING FOR OPPORTUNITY
FOR BETTER SALARIES I KNOW MY
FATHER WAS A FARM WORKER. SO
IT'S UNDENIABLE THAT PERFORMING
ARTS PEOPLE HAD IN HAND. WITH
WHAT THE MOVEMENT AND IT'S
CRITICAL TO THE FABRIC OF OUR
SOCIETY AT A LOCAL LEVEL I CAN
SHARE WITH YOU THAT THE FUNDING
FOR ARTS IN OUR SCHOOLS IS
DISAPPEARING I WAS A TEACHER
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS IT'S
INCREDIBLE HOW MUCH PARTS WE
HAD WHEN I STARTED NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS AGO AND WHERE
WE'RE AT NOW OUR CHILDREN ARE
NOT BEING EXPOSED TO WHAT THEY
NEED TO BECOME WELL ROUNDED
INDIVIDUALS. AND I PERSONALLY
DON'T WANT TO GO BACK TO A TIME
WHERE THE ARTS THEATER IS ONLY
FOR THE WEALTHY WE SHOULD
ALWAYS MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE TO
THE BILL'S IN INNER CITY
COMMUNITIES WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
NEVER SEE A PLAY A SHALL BE
INTRIGUED BY THE POSSIBILITIES
THE ARTS CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
IT OPENS DOORS ESPECIALLY FOR
CHILDREN LIKE MYSELF WHERE ARE
YOU SAW WITH NOTHING BUT
NEGATIVE ELEMENTS. PLEASE HELP
ME. SAY SMALL. TODAY WITH ME
I'M HONORED TO HAVE TWO
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS WITH ME
FIRST I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE.
THE FETAL BIRTH AND AWARD
WINNING PLAYWRIGHT WHO ROLLED
WILL ROOM WITH REAL WOMEN HAVE
CURVES. AND SHE ALSO WAS THE
OCT UP FOUNDER AND ARTISTIC
DIRECTOR OF CASA ZERO ONE ZERO
ONE IN BOYLE HEIGHTS I ALSO
HAVE THE ICONIC LABOR LEADER
DOLORES HUERTA HOLTBY SPEAKING.
I TOOK PART. OF EIGHT OH FIVE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OKAY
THINK SENATOR- WE WILL NOW TURN
TO LEAD SUPPORT- AND THAT IS
THE WORST WERE TO PRESERVE
FUNDED OR SUPPORTED FOUNDATION
CO FOUNDERS OF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION- RESORT TO IF YOU
WERE AVAILABLE YOU MAY PROCEED.
PERFECT JUST TO CLARIFY WE ALSO
HAVE FULL SIGNAL UP IF YOU'RE A
PERSON WITH ME. IF YOU WANT YOU
WANT TO PROCEED WITH THE IN
PERSON TESTIMONY FIRST SO IF
YOU'RE SAYING. IF I MAY PLEASE
THAT'S FINE THANK YOU. THE
DOORS IF YOU CAN JUST PAUSE FOR
A MOMENT I APOLOGIZE SIR. WE
HAVE A PER IN PERSON SPEAKER
HERE. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
FIRST- I WAS PROCEED DON'T WANT
TO GO OUT OF THE AFTER HER
BECAUSE A POWER HOUSE. OKAY
ASSEMBLY ASKED TO GO FOR HER.
SO I'M ALSO IF YOU DON'T OFFICE
AND I WROTE REAL WOMEN HAVE
CURVES I WROTE THIS PLAY S A
CELEBRATION OF MY MOTHER WAS A
SEAMSTRESS. I ALSO WROTE IT TO
CELEBRATE THE FACT THAT I WAS
UNDOCUMENTED AND I GOT AMNESTY
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND IT
BECAME A LEGAL RESIDENT- THIS
PLAYED A ROLE BECAME A HUGE
SUCCESS WITH OVER A HUNDRED
PRODUCTIONS THROUGHOUT THE US.
IT ALSO THE FILM HAS- HAS BEEN
INDUCTED INTO THE NATIONAL
REGISTRY AT THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS BECAUSE OF ITS
CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE AND ITS
CULTURAL VALUE. ADD THIS FILM
WAS GOING TO BE ONE OF THE FEW
pMUSEUM OF THE MOTION PICTURE
ACADEMY. BUT WHEN I WAS GETTING
STARTED AS A WRITER AND I WAS
TRYING TO GET THIS PLAY
PRODUCED. NOBODY WOULD PRODUCE
MY PLAYING ANOTHER BIG THEATERS
WILL PRODUCE MY PLATE IT WAS A
LOT OF RACIST THINGS ABOUT WHAT
THE NOSE. AND I GOT SO SICK AND
TIRED OF IT. DID I DECIDED TO
PRODUCE MY OWN PLACE. LET'S
START MY OWN THEATER COMPANY.
HOW IS IT FAIR THAT LATINOS OF
THE MAJORITY IN LOS ANGELES.
AND YET WE ARE INVISIBLE IN
CINEMA TV AND THEATRE AS YOU
CAN TELL BY THE OSCARS WE
WEREN'T THERE. I STARTED MY OWN
SMALL THEATER. SO THAT I CAN
TELL STORIES ABOUT LATINOS SO
THAT I CAN EDUCATE MY COMMUNITY
TO TELL OUR STORIES. I GET VERY
EMOTIONAL ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
THE TO SAVE MY LIFE. PETER IS
NOT JUST ENTERTAINMENT FOR THE
RICH IT'S NOT JUST
ENTERTAINMENT IT REALLY IS
ABOUT AFFIRMING YOUR HUMANITY
YOUR DIGNITY. AND I'VE USED MY
SMALL THEATER. TO SHOW MY
COMMUNITY THERE WE MATTER. AND
THAT WE ARE BEING HEARD AND
THAT WE ARE VISIBLE. IT HAS
BEEN MY SMALL PETER HAS BEEN MY
WAY OF CREATING A COMMUNITY SO
WE CAN ALSO HEAR THE TRAUMA
THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH DRAMA IN
MY COMMUNITY BECAUSE IT USED TO
BE KNOWN AS THE GANG CAPITAL OF
THE UNITED STATES. SMALL
THEATERS ARE THE ONLY WAY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES GET
THEIR STORIES TOLD. SMALL
FEEDERS ALLOW FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR TO HAVE THEIR DREAMS COME
TRUE BECAUSE WE GET TO SEE THEM
ON STAGE IT WILL WE SEE
OURSELVES AS THE PROTAGONIST OF
OUR LIVES WE GET TO SEE BE TE
HEROES BECAUSE WE'RE TIRED OF
PLAYING THE VILLAINS WE ARE
TIRED OF BEING THEM WE WANT TO
SEE OURSELVES REPRESENTED. IN
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY WE CAN.
SENATORS SMALL FEEDERS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO TELL STORIES. I'VE
STRUGGLED. REPRESENTATION
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY. I'M SORRY
I GET SO EMOTIONAL BUT TO ME
IT'S MORE THAN JUST OF. IT IS
SIGNIFICANT LITTLE THING YOU
KNOW THIS IS MY LIFE. THERE'S
SO MUCH INJUSTICE AT LEAST
EVERY COULD TELL STORIES WHERE
WE GET SOME KIND OF JUSTICE IN
ON STAGE. THESE WARM SUPER
HEART TO KEEP FIGHTING. SO YOU
WERE DUE TO SUPPORT SMALL
FEEDERS ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW
WHEN WE CAN CREATE A BETTER
WORLD WITH THEIR STORIES. SMALL
PETER INSPIRES OUR COMMUNITY TO
KEEP GOING. PLEASE I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT ZERO
FIVE THANK YOU- THANK YOU
YOURSELF INTO A WILL GO BACK TO
THE DOOR SUPPORT. ON THE ON THE
CONFERENCE ONE PLEASE. THANK
YOU FOR CHOOSING. I THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THE BILL.
BUDGET THIS IS GOING ON FOR NOW
AFTER- DURING AFTER THE ROOT
THE DEPRESSION IN THE THIRTIES-
FRANKLIN DON'T DONALD GLOVER
PRESIDENT. I HAD MANY MANY
ARTISTS THAT THEY HIRED TO DO
THEATER TO DO OUR TO DO LOSING
AND THAT WAS PART OF PEOPLE
COMING OUT OF THE OUT OF THE
DEPRESSION. BUT WE HAVE HAD A
SIMILAR INCIDENT WELL- WITH THE
PANDEMIC IT BUT PEOPLE GONE TO
SO PEOPLE ARE STARVED. STARVED
FOR ENTERTAINMENT. SEVEN IN A
ROW AREAS ARE. YOUR IN THE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY CALIFORNIA.
WE CAN HELP HERE DON'T DON'T
GET TO GO TO LOS ANGELES- TERMS
GOING TO THAT THEY ARE TO DO SO
MAKE IT OCCURRED. TO COMMUNITY
THEATER IS A VERY VITAL. OF OUR
CONCERN THAT PART OF OUR LIFE.
AND IT'S ENOUGH PEOPLE ARE
START PRINTED PAYMENT RIGHT NOW
BUT A COMMUNITY THEATER BIRTH
FOR THE ENTERTAINMENT IT BRINGS
EDUCATION. DETECTION FOR HEARTS
AND THE MINDS OF THE PEOPLE
THEY NEED TO LEARN ABOUT THE
COMPLEX ISSUES THE POSTAL
ADDRESSES ISSUES THAT WE'RE ALL
WORKING ON A TWO DAY LIKE WHICH
OF JUSTICE. THAT WILL BE A-
ECONOMIC INTER. GENERALLY IN
THE IS. ARE KNOWN AND I THAT
THEIR. RUBIO RICHARD SHOULDN'T
COMPANY. AT THE DIPLOMA COULD
LOOM DILLON BEFORE THERE'S
CAPITA CONFERENCE. AND. TO YOU
HAVE THE MIDDLE YOU KNOW IT
SHOULD BE TELLING PEOPLE ABOUT
THE CONDITION OF THE- WORKS
ISN'T GOING TO HELP US TERMS OF
THE GREAT PLACE. INTO THE WILL
BRING THE NEW YORK SACRAMENTO
HERE AND- TO THE WORKERS
BECAUSE VERY IMPORTANT BILL I
THINK VERY YOU'LL IN THE WAY
IT'S GOING. I HAVE BEEN A
CONVERSATION- WHAT THE IS OF
LABOR BUT TO MAKE SURE. THE
BILL KNOCKED CALL THE CURRENT
YEAR- BUT WORKING PEOPLE
BECAUSE WE KNOW ARE STILL. I DO
WANNA THANK LOOK AT. BRADFORD
ARE YOU OPENING UP THEATER
FACTOR IN THE SANDERS WHO
LATELY SMOKING. AND I DO HOPE
THAT THE COMMITTEE HERE HELLO
SHE- IMPORTANT. YOUR ENTRY THE
LIFEBOAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US TODAY BUT WE WILL ASK IF
THERE ARE OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE COMMITTEE'S FOR TWO OR
THREE. WHO IS TO SPEAK COME FOR
C. NONE OF CHECK YOUR FOR ROOM
OTHERS ON CARE TO BE ANY THERE
TO SPEAK CONSERVE OF THE BILL
OF MODERATOR- WE WILL ASK YOU
TO QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES SAID THAT YOU HAVE.
ON SENATE BILL EIGHT OH FIVE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
NINE ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANYTHING CHAIR MEMBERS I
THOUGHT HE TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND OF
THE JUST A MOMENT WE DO HAVE
THIRTEEN OTHERS IN QUEUE AT THE
TIME THIS TIME AND WE'RE JUST
GATHERING MY NUMBERS YES IN
WELL YOU'RE GATHERING THEM- I
JUST DO WANT TO REMIND THAT
THIS PORTION OF THE TESTIMONY
IS FOR NAME AFFILIATION. IN
SUPPORT ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MINE ONE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURIE NOBODY THOUGHT
FEDA OF WRITER DIRECTOR
PRODUCER ACTOR AND PARENTS
ABOUT JUSTIN CONCEPTS AT ALMOST
AT ONE OF THE- IN BOYLE HEIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR VOTING FOR JUST A
SMALL STAGE IN CALIFORNIA TODAY
YOUR SUPPORT MEANS THAT THAT
LIKE PART OF OUR COMMUNITY. ALL
YOU HAVE TO STOP THEIR
ASSIGNMENT RIGHT I'M SORRY NAME
AFFILIATION. IN SUPPORT ONLY
PLEASE. ONE ONE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THAT
THEY'VE GOT THAT ON I AM THE
FOUNDING ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF
AFFILIATE JUMP PRODUCTIONS AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
THEATRICAL PRODUCERS MAKE OF
LOS ANGELES AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- AYE VOTE ON AT THE L.
FIVE. EIGHT O'CLOCK. ONE ONE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
SHEILA MALONE AND I AM A
FREELANCE ARTIST IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA IN THE COURT OF SB
EIGHT ZERO FIVE THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
NINE WEEKS AGO IAN AND I MANY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO
BENEFITTED FROM THE PERFORMING
ARTS. IN CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT AND BE EIGHT OR
FIVE THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JEAN
WITHOUT HIS TAIL AND THE
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF THE NEW
AMERICAN THEATER I AM ALSO AN
ARTIST AND I SUPPORT S. B.
EIGHT OH FIVE. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ALEXEY OF THE SEVENTEEN
YEAR PARENT OF TWO CHILDREN IN
THEATER AND THE PRESIDENT OF
CHILDREN'S EDUCATIONAL THEATER
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH FIVE
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A MANUAL
DALY HONESTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF COST OF THEIR WONDER ONE
THEATER AND I SUPPORT SB. EIGHT
OH FIVE. FIND ONE FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS VIRGINIA
MORRIS AND FORMER ARTISTIC
DIRECTOR PRODUCER OF
SHAPESHIFTER PRODUCTIONS IN LA
AND ULTRA FOUR YEARS LATER
CORRECTED THE CELTIC ARTS
CENTER I SUPPORT SB. EIGHT OH
FIVE. NINE ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I'M SAMANTHA BARIO SOME
MARKETING CHAIR THEY CAN PUT
PLAYERS AND VETERAN OF THE
SMOKING IN LOS ANGELES AND I
SUPPORT STRONG SUPPORT SB EIGHT
OH FIVE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CHRISTY SOMEBODY I AM THE
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF AND DENTAL
CAMPESINO INCOME FUND OUT THE
STOCK I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB. EIGHT OH FIVE. NINE ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH AT THE I KNOW I AM AN
ARTIST AND COMMUNITY MEMBER AND
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND I AM
CALLING AND SUPPORT SB EIGHT OH
FIVE I ALSO HAVE SOMEONE OUT
HERE. HELLO MY NAME CAN BE
ACTED ALONE NOW. SO POOR AND HE.
J. O. TIENEN THANK YOU. OF THE-
ONE ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DANIEL SHANNON FROM THE
ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF IN CLOSE
EITHER THANKS COULD YOU PLEASE
SUPPORT SB. EIGHT OH FIVE. NINE
ONE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CLASS
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
MANY WITH PHILLY BAGNALL AND I
AM A PROFESSOR IF YOU COULD
FIND A COLLEGE I AM AT A G. B.
T. Q. AND I SUPPORT SB EIGHT OH
FIVE. NINE ONE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE FORTY SIX IF YOU MAY
REPEAT. I AM CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE THEATRICAL HE LOS
ANGELES. SO YOUR GOOGLE ACCOUNT
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. IT YOUR-
PERMIT SHUTTER THE WHOLE
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
SUPPORT QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL COME BACK HOME
TO OPPOSITION THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE THE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS EDUARDO MARTINEZ SO
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IF
YOU'RE A CALLING IN YOU'RE-
WELCOME TO PROCEED. FOR THE
YEAR MUSIKER YES WE CAN HURRY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION-
WE'RE HERE WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION- ONE TO
START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS THAT MOVE
THIS BILL AWAY FROM AN EIGHTY
FIVE EXEMPTION AND TOWARDS A
PAYMENT PAGEMASTER CONCEPT AN
IDEA THAT MANY OF OUR UNIONS
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON FOR SOME
TIME. WHAT WE ARE STILL IN
OPPOSITION WERE COMFORTABLE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AT THE BILL MOVES AND
COMMITTEE TODAY- ADMITTED B.
YOU DON'T. HATCHER PROMISE
TREMENDOUS PROMISE TO NOT ONLY
IF THEY'RE STRUGGLING COMMUNITY
LEADERS. BUT ALSO THE BROADER
THEATER WORKFORCE MANY OF WHOM
HAVE BEEN OUT OF WORK MUCH OF
THIS PANDEMIC. AND WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY ASKING SENATOR
RUBIO AND THE COMMITTEE TO WORK
WITHOUT AN ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT OR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THAT ADDRESS MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT THE THAT THE- PUBLIC WENT
UP BUT- SUPPORTED WITNESSES
STATED- IF I COULD JUST
ALUMINUM RIGHT SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS. NUMBER ONE WE WANT TO
SEE WE'RE SEEKING CLARIFICATION
IN THE BILL THAT NOTHING
CHANGES THE EMPLOYMENT STATUS
OF THE THEATER EMPLOYEES.
SPECIFICALLY WE WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES
RECEIVE THEIR WAGES IF
PAYMASTER ENTITY THE REMAINING
CLEAN OF THE CATERING WHICH
THEY WORK. WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO SEE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT IT KNOWLEDGE IS THOSE
COMMUNITIES THEATERS THAT HAVE
ALREADY DONE RIGHT BY THEIR
WORKERS. EITHER BY ENTERING
INTO A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT CREATING HIGH ROAD
CAREER PATHWAYS OR SOME OTHER
INVESTMENT IN THEIR WORKFORCE-
THIRD WE'D LIKE TO SUGGEST THAT
A DIFFERENT ENTITY OTHER THAN
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
GOVERNED BURKE DISBURSEMENT OF
THE FUND. MANY GREAT EXAMPLES
OF JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE THAT HAVE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED GRANT PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT. AND LASTLY WE'D LIKE TO
WE'D LIKE THEATERS TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IN THEIR
APPLICATION ABOUT THEIR WORK
FORCE. REACHED IN DATA POINTS
LIKE HOW MANY W. TWO EMPLOYEES
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THAT
THE THEATER HAVE. A DOES THE
THEATER HAVE DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION POLICIES AND HOW
BIGGER ISSUES AND OF. BUT
SOMETHING WE CAN ADDRESS THESE
REMAINING ISSUES ARE UNIONS ARE
NOT ONLY JUST PREPARED TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION BUT
INSTEAD ARE PREPARED TO JOIN
SENATOR RUBIO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. TO GET THIS PROGRAM UP
AND RUNNING I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK MISS MARTINEZ SOME
WILL MOVE. A WITNESSES HERE IN
THE ROOM WERE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. TO S. B. A
FIFTY. KATO FIVE I'M SORRY.
COURTESY NONE WILL MOVE TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM ON S. B. ETAL
FIVE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SEEN NONE WILL GO BACK TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED THERE'S ANYONE
ON THE TELECONFERENCE WIND WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
THE SENATE BILL EIGHT OH FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHT ZERO FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SIX THREE THREE MOBILE
REMOVED HIMSELF FROM Q. WE HAVE
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU MODERATOR- WILL COME
BACK TO THE TO THE COMMITTEE
AND- LET ME SEE IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ME
DEPENDING ON HOW THE STYLE GOES
I MAY HAVE SOME MYSELF PUT THEM
CENTER WE'RE GONNA START WITH
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU- I THINK
THAT THAT THE AUTHOR IS QUITE
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE SUBJECT
AND SHE STARTED WITH THAT A. B.
FIVE ISSUE AND SHE AMENDED OUT.
AND SHE'S WORKED HARD ON THIS
ONE AND THERE STILL WAS THE
OPPOSE US AMENDED FROM THE
LABOR FEDERATION WHICH ACTUALLY
SAID THEY WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK AND SO- ARE OUR HIGH AM
PREPARED TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
AND I THINK THAT THE REAL ISSUE
IS THAT- FRANKLY COME HELL OR
HIGH WATER OF THE AUTHOR'S
GOING TO MAKE THIS WORK AND SO
THE QUESTION IS WHAT
FORMULATION TO SHE FINALLY GOT
TO DO THAT AND I JUST WANT TO
GIVE HER THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
GET THERE AND- I THINK THAT THE
IF THIS ONE DOESN'T QUITE WORK
AND SHE CAN FIGURE OUT
SOMETHING ELSE THAT
ACCOMPLISHES THE PURPOSE MORE
POWER TO. ED WE DID TODAY WE
CAN JUST GIVE HER THE OPTION OF
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS AND
MEETING THE GOAL THIS BILL SO
I'LL BE PREPARED T MOVE IT
WHENEVER. WE GET TO THAT TIME.
CERVERA'S OF. YES ARM. ARE ONE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL WORK THAT
AUTHOR HAS DONE I KNOW WE HAD
A- LONG CONVERSATION ABOUT IT
AND- I KNOW THERE'S A GOAL
THAT. SHE'S EXPLAINED TO ME
THAT SHE HAS IN MIND. LAW AND
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE SMALL
THEATERS AND WHAT THEY MEAN TO
OUR COMMUNITY SO. ON THAT. ON
THAT PAGE WERE WERE RIGHT IN
SYNC WITH EACH OTHER SO. I I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
MOVING OUT OF THE COMMITTEE SO
THAT YOU CAN CONTINUE TO DO.
THE WORK WITH THE- WITH THE
LABOR- ORGANIZATIONS AND- AND
GET TO THE POINT WHERE. WE ALL
FEEL REALLY GREAT ESPECIALLY
THE SMALL THEATERS THANK YOU-
SOONER THANK YOU A MEMBERSHIP.
THANK YOU DEAR THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR- WE BEGIN BY
SAYING THAT HAVE A GREAT LOVE
FOR THE ARTS- AND I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT MY CHILDREN
WERE ACTUALLY MEMBERS OF OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY AB SMALL
THEATERS- AND THEY DID THAT FOR
MANY MANY YEARS WHEN THEY WERE
LITTLE- I KNOW THE SACRIFICES
THE TIME THE COMMITMENT AND THE
PASSION THAT OUR LITTLE
THEATERS HAVE- THE LEADERS THAT
LEAD OUR THE OUR LOCAL THEATERS
DO ADD I HAD SOME GREAT
CONVERSATIONS EARLY ON WITH
REGARDS TO- THEIR INTENT- EARLY
ON WHEN THEY STARTED
APPROACHING OUR OFFICE AND
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND-
I WAS JUST. VERY MUCH A
SUPPORTER OF THE LOCAL ARTS-
AND I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
FOR THE NONPROFIT PERFORMING
ARTS CENTER SPECIALLY DURING
THIS PANDEMIC THIS BILL HOWEVER
IT IN MY OPINION IS NOT A
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM THIS
INTERCITY CANNOT SURVIVE UNDER
THE RESTRICTIONS OF AB FIVE AND
SHOULD BE EXEMPTED FROM IT. AS
A HUNDRED AND SEVEN OTHER
PROFESSIONS HAVE BEEN. AS THAT
WOULD BE THE MOST FEASIBLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION. FOR
THOSE REASONS I WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
AS I WOULD LOVE FOR THEM TO BE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE AND- BE ABLE TO
FOLLOW WHAT IT IS THAT THEIR
INTENT WAS ORIGINALLY. AND FOR
THAT I HI- I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING IT BUT I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT THAT YOU'RE PUTTING
FORWARD. ON ON THIS EFFORT AND
DO WISH YOU. THE VERY BEST AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER NEWMAN AT
THANK YOU MISTER I JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF. MY
COLLEAGUES HERE TO SAY- I THINK
WE ALL BELIEVE IN THE ARCH
OPTION RUBIO YOUR COMMITMENT
IS. OBVIOUSLY REALLY ADMIRABLE
AND SO I ALSO WANNA GIVE YOU
CREDIT FOR YOUR DOG GETTING
CREATIVE PERSISTENCE IN TRYING
TO GET THIS. TO A STATE THAT WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD I'M I'M
ACTUALLY VERY ENCOURAGED TO SEE
THAT YOU'VE DONE SO- A PLEASED
TO HEAR THAT THE DATE YOU IN
LABOR SAID WE WORKING TOGETHER%
TO ADDRESS ANY REMAINING
ISSUES. AND SO I WILL BE GLAD
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. IT
IS IMPORTANT NOTED THE PANDEMIC
HAS BEEN DEVASTATING TO SO MANY
INDUSTRIES NONE MORE THAN THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES SO THANK
YOU. FOR REPRESENTING THESE
PEOPLE- WE CANNOT LET THEIR
WORK GO UNNOTICED WE CANNOT
LIKE LET THEIR WORK. DIES SO
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
INCLUDES FOR THE BILL. THANK
YOU SIR NEWMAN. YES IT LIMIT
LET ME JUST THE CITY OF FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU FOR OPENING A
PRESENTATION BY INDICATING-
RIGHT AWAY VIA THE PATH THAT
THIS BILL HAS BEEN ON THE
TRAJECTORY FROM. YOU TAKING IT
UP ON BEHALF OF THE INCOME.
FOLKS WHO WHO FELT THAT THE-
COULDN'T SURVIVE. WITHOUT THE
LEVY EIGHTY FIVE AND THEN TURN
THIS INTO. A REVENUE SIDE OF
MEASURE REALLY THAT SAYS- LET'S
LEAVE THAT ALONE AND LET'S
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN. FIGURE
OUT FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN. DEAL
WITH THE PROBLEM IN A DIFFERENT
WAY SO IT'S VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED- THAT YOU YOU KNOW
WORK HARD CONSULTING- ME THIS
COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE- I KNOW
YOU'VE- BEEN- DEALING WITH
OPPOSITION WE HEARD THAT FROM
THEM- HOPEFULLY IT SOME OF
THESE. OPPOSITION COMMENTS
WOULD. SEEM REASONABLE CAN BE.
HANDLE ON THE WAY ARE CERTAIN I
NOT THE UP ON THE SEX HERE AND
TURN OF PROCESS BUT CERTAINLY
AT LEAST ONE OF THOSE ISSUES IF
NOT TO. A WERE APPROPRIATIONS
KINDS OF ISSUES US IN TERMS OF
WHAT. THE ULTIMATELY SHOULD BE.
ATTACHED TO THE BILL IN TERMS
OF CONDITIONS FOR APPLICANTS
AND SO FORTH- BUT I UNDERSTAND-
FROM YOUR COMMENTS- IN THE END
YOU MAY WANT TO INTERESTED IN
YOUR CLOTHES THAT CERTAINLY
YOUR PREROGATIVE- THAT YOU YOU
WISH TO CONTINUE TO WORK THINGS
OUT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
COMMENTS HERE- FROM. OUR
COLLEAGUES- MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF. THE
EXPECTATION THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK- NOT ONLY WITH
THE- BUT- OFTEN ALONG THE WAY
TO MAKE THE BILL- REALLY WORK-
FOR EVERYONE AND- I THINK WITH
ALL OF THE HEAR THAT FROM YOU
BUT- IN ANY CASE. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO CLOSE ON YOUR OWN
TERMS AT THIS TIME. AND AND
THEN WILL TAKE UP THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
DID HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH A
BOTTLE EARLIER TODAY ON
BREAKING EXPRESS WHAT HE WANTED
TO SEE- I HAVEN'T THE NECESSARY
SAT DOWN WITH HIM TO. GET TO
TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES IN
DETAIL BUT I TOLD THEM THAT.
JUST LIKE I WAS ABLE TO. GET MY
BILL AND LITERALLY MOVE A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION AT THE
REQUEST OF BADGES YOU KNOW.
GIVE THEM AN INDICATION THAT
I'M OPEN FOR DISCUSSIONS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE THEM
ABSOLUTELY- I ALSO WANT TO TAKE
THE TIME TO JUST THANK EVERYONE
AT THE LABOR FED FOR CONSISTENT
CONTINUOUSLY COMING TO MY
OFFICE HE HAD SO MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY STUFF
AND- STAKEHOLDERS AND- I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE COALITION OF
ADVOCATES. AGAIN LOTS OF
MEETINGS AND LOTS OF HOURS- IN
THE LAST MONTH. ALL BUT IN
PARTICULAR ON THE LOTUS WHAT
THE FOR TAKING THE TIME TO CALL
IN TODAY IT'S VERY. MEANINGFUL
TO ME SOMEONE AT BANKER ON
ANIMAL TAKING A LITTLE BIT WHO
FLEW UP HERE TO GET HER
PERSONAL TESTIMONY. AND YOU
KNOW I WAS REALLY MOVED BY HER
TESTIMONY AND HER. APOLOGIZING
FOR GETTING EMOTIONAL BUT- I
DON'T SEE WHY SHE SHOULD
APOLOGIZE I'VE KNOWN HER
FIFTEEN A FOR MANY YEARS NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS WHEN SHE STARTED
HER THEATER. I SAW HOW SHE PUT
HER HEART AND SOUL INTO THIS
BUSINESS AND THE FACT THAT
SHE'S CRYING. YOU KNOW SHE GIVE
US AN INDICATION HOW
DESPERATELY NEED AT THIS BILL
IS SHE WAS SHARING WITH ME THAT
THEY HAVEN'T OPENED THIS WHOLE
ENTIRE YEAR OR SO. IT'S NO
WONDER. YOU KNOW WE NEED THIS
BILL SELDOM. IS TO READ FIGURE
OUT A WAY HOW TO SEE THE SMALL.
THERE MEANINGFUL SIGNET JUST
GENERALLY. BUT IN PARTICULAR
THE WHOLE CYCLE FIFTEEN ON ONE
VESTED EVERYTHING THEY HAD. FOR
DECADES TRYING TO MAKE
SOMETHING WORK AND SO WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROOM. DO WE- KNOW
SOMEONE INDICATED EMOTION
CENTER EARLIER DID. A SO WE
HAVE A MOTION AND- WE WILL- AS
MISTER FURRER CONSULTANT TO-
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE THIS
TIME. THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CORTEZ EIGHT HI.
SENATOR CORTEZ III SENATOR- JOB
NO. SENATOR CHOKE NO SENATOR
ALSO. SENATOR TORONTO II CENTER
LAYERED HI CENTER LAYERED HI
SENATOR NEWMAN. CENTER NEWMAN
HI. THE TO ONE SO THE BILL IS A
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MESSAGE. BUT
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO. OUR LAST
BILL FROM. EINEM HE MAYBE WE
WILL GO AHEAD I WAS GOING WITH
THE CALL BUT WHEN WE GO AHEAD
AND- IT MOVED TO ITEM EIGHT AND
THEN WILL A CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ON PRIOR- PRIOR VOTING
AFTER WE HEAR IT SENATE BILL
FOR. ONE NINE FOUR NINETEEN
SENATOR STERN'S BILL. IS
SENATOR STERN. I BELIEVE YOU
ARE WITH US REMOTELY TODAY
THAT'S- OKAY MISTER CHAIR GOOD
OKAY YOU YOU MAY PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MEMBERS FIRST ONLY
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE ANALYSIS. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SB FOUR
NINETEEN WHICH AT ITS CORE IS
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF OUR OIL AND
GAS WELLS IN THIS STATE. AND
RELYING ON. THE MOST SKILLED
WORKERS I DECIDE SUBMIT IN THE
WHOLE COUNTRY IN THE OIL AND
GAS SECTOR HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
GIVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK A
TRADE AN HONEST DAY'S WORK- BUT
IN MAKING OUR COMMUNITY SAFER.
IN THE PROCESS. WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE ACTUALLY- VERY LARGE OIL
OIL PRODUCING STATE AS WELL AS
SOME GAS AND MANY OF THESE.
OPERATIONS IN LARGE INDUSTRIAL
SECTORS IN SUMMER IT CLOSER TO
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
BUT- THE KEY IS THAT FOR ALL
THAT OIL AND GAS INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO MIDSTREAM
SERVICES. THE KIND OF WORK THAT
GOES AROUND THE WELL HEAD- WHEN
IT COMES TO HOW TO PLUG AND
ABANDON A WELL. TO BLOCK IT UP
WITH THE- CEMENT DIDN'T MAKE IT
GO AWAY AFTER IT'S BEEN
COLLUDING IN THE COMMUNITY FOR
YEARS OR JUST TO SIMPLY-
TIGHTEN UP THE SURROUNDING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE SURE
THERE NO LEAKS AND THAT- PEOPLE
NEARBY ARE KEPT AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE. THE FACT IS THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THAT WORK HAS
BEEN DONE OVER THE LAST MANY
YEARS BY TURN AROUND
CONTRACTORS MANY OF WHOM ARE
FROM OUT OF STATE. AND I THINK
THAT IN CALIFORNIA ARE WORKING
PEOPLE ARE THE BEST POSITION TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
SO THAT'S WHY RUNNING THIS
LEGISLATION- TO ENSURE THAT-
DATE THE BEST SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKERS ARE ABLE TO DO.
THE WORK- IN THE OIL AND GAS
SECTOR THAT THE STATE SO
DESPERATELY NEEDS- I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A CRITICAL PART OF
THE AMERICAN JOBS PLANNED
ROLLOUT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I THINK THEY'RE.
REALLY BIG OPPORTUNITY STIFF TO
BROKER- I'M LIKE PART. BETWEEN
LATE AND FRIENDLY TO ME HERE
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES AND RIGHT NOW THAT
THAT OPPORTUNITY MAY SEEM
IMPOSSIBLE OR BLEAK OUTLOOK-
AND THEN ALSO I DURING THEIR
CORNERS BUT I TRULY THINK THAT
IF WE- WE PAY DUE RESPECT AND
ACTUALLY LEVERAGE THE EXPERTISE
OF THE WORKING PEOPLE AND OIL
AND GAS. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE CAN ACTUALLY
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE AND MAKE
OURSELVES SAFER IN THE PROCESS
SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR
ROOM WE WILL MOVE TO LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES- WE HAVE
SCOTT WHICH INTERNATIONAL THE
ROLEX WORKERS REPRESENTING
THEM. HERE IN THE ROOM. AND
MARTIN RODRIGUEZ- WHO WILL BE
CALLING ON THE COAST
TELECONFERENCE ALLIANCE WILL
START. MISTER WELCH. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. AND THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS. AS
NO EXISTING LAW REQUIRES A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
WITH IN THE REFINERIES DURING
TURNAROUND WORK. THAT'S BECAUSE
THESE ARE VERY DANGEROUS JOBS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BOILERS-
FLAMMABLE GAS HI PRESSURIZED
PIPES THAT CARRY GAS OIL.
STEAMED VERY DANGEROUS WORK AND
THAT'S THE ESSENCE OF THE
REASON FOR THE REQUIREMENT OF A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. THE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION SUGGESTS AN
AMENDMENT. CERTIFIED
ELECTRICIANS WHO ARE CERTIFIED
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
QUALIFY AS SKILLED AND TRAINED
REGARDLESS IF THEY'VE GRADUATED
FROM STATUS APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. GOING
OUT THAT YOU CAN BECOME A
CERTIFIED ELECTRICIAN THROUGH A
TRAINEE PROGRAM. THE MESSAGE
TELL THE COMMITTEE THAT A
TRAINEE PROGRAMMES DID NOT COME
CLOSE TO EQUALISING AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THAT
REQUIRES FIVE YEARS OF
INDENTURED SERVITUDE AND-
INSTRUCT INTENSE INSTRUCTION IN
THE CLASSROOM FOR FIVE YEARS
THE REASON WHY THE NONUNION
CONTRACTORS. PREFER TRAINEE
PROGRAM IS AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS HAVE A MINIMUM WAGE
REQUIREMENT IN THE MINIMUM WAGE
REQUIREMENT DOES NOT APPLY TO
TRAINEES. BUT THERE ARE NON
UNION- A PRINTER PROGRAMS IN
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THEY DON'T
GRADUATE ANYBODY SO THEY HAVE A
PATHWAY BUT THEY DON'T INVEST A
LITTLE GRADUATE THE KIDS THAT'S
WHY THEY WANT TO MISDIRECT
TOWARDS TRAINING PROGRAMS.
LASTLY I WOULD POINT OUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZES
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AS THE
HEIGHTENED LOOKED AT THE TOP
LEVEL OF TRAINING IS THAT WE
REQUIRE THAT ONE AFRAID TO
SPEAK POINT FOR EVERY FIGHT
JOURNEYMEN ON EVERY SINGLE
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT IN THE
STATE. THAT IS NOT A STANDARD
THAT APPLIES TO ANY OTHER
TRAINING PROGRAM. FOR THESE
REASONS READ URGENT AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. FOR THE YOU MISTER
WILL- MOVING TO- THE HORN
RODRIGUEZ. IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE YOU MAY PROCEED PRESIDENT
TRY COME IS BOOMING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. AB
MARTIN RODRIGUEZ I ALWAYS
BUSINESS AGENT FOR THIRTY THREE
IN TRI COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
PRESIDENT ELLEN INVENTOR. THANK
YOU WOULD GIVE ME A CHANCE TO
TALK ON THIS BILL. SO
IMPORTANT. THAT THIS BILL CAME
OUT AND IMELY YOU KNOW WAR
LOOK AND EVERYONE'S ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT THE TRANSITION
AND HOW WE GONNA DO IT BUT
NOBODY HAS. A CLUE. UNTIL THIS
BILL CAME UP OR NOBODY HAD A
REAL PLAN THIS IS THE PLAN AND
THE BILL THAT WILL WORK. BY
UPGRADING THE SKILL SETS OF THE
WORKERS THAT. ARE ALREADY
PERFORMING THIS WORK. WHAT ARE
ADDED PER. AND MILLER HIGHLY
SKILLED WORKERS OF THE BUILDING.
SIDE OF THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY. I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT THIS. A FEW OF THESE-
WE WILL THE AND THE- THE WORK
FORCE OF THE FUTURE THAT WILL
BUILD A SUSTAINABLE. THAT ARE
ON OF. FOR THE- NEAR FUTURE AS
WELL AS CARBON CAP TAKE THAT IS
BEING. I HOPE YOU TO IN THE
CONSIDERATION CONSIDERING- ALL
THE THAT ARE THAT WORK LIVE IN
THESE COULD. AND- RE'S
THERE'S NOT ONLY THEIR- BUT FOR
JUST BEING ABLE TO LIVE- INK.
WITHOUT A GOOD DAY IN JOBS
BENEFITS. BILL ADDRESSES THAT.
IT OKAY TO SAY AGAIN HOW I
DON'T IT IS- TO PASS THE THAT
IS TIME AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL YOU ALL. THANK YOU AND WHO
YOU'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE TO
ANYWAY WE SWITCH TO SPEAK
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM AND THIS
PORTION THE OF- IS. BOTH IN IN
ON THE TOP SO LIMITED TO A NAME
OF. AND SO AND CASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY'S HERE
ON BEHALF THE EAST BUILDING CAN.
TRADES COUNCIL PROUD SPONSORS
THANK. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE BELL ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNET BROTHER
OF BOYS AND STROKES OF. OKAY
THANK YOU ANYONE KNOW IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO. IN SOME OF S.
B. NINETY- ANYONE IN THE OVER
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY SUPPORT
OF NINETY. C. NONE REMOVED TO
THE MATER ASKED FOR. ANYONE ON
TELECOM OR WAS WHO WAS TO SPEAK
IN SOME OF S. B. FOUR NINE AND
IF YOU PLEASE LET US KNOW- THE
NO IN THE KEY WE WOULD. THAT.
THANK YOU MISS CHAIR. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN YOU WISH
TO AND SO OF S. FOUR NINE YOU
MAY PRESS AND THEN TO AT TIME.
AND WE HAVE. TEN IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU. MY SEVENTEEN YEAR
LINE OPEN GO OUT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS A YOUR
MARRIAGE PRESIDENT OF NORTH
STREET BELOW COAL THE YOUR
STATES WORKER IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT OF
BILL. MY NAME OWNER. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR HAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JAMES THERE ARE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LABOR IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
SHERRIN MEMBERS AND OTHERS SAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. MY
NINETY TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MOP COMMITTEE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE PROPERTY ENGINEERS
FINANCE FONG COURT THANK YOU.
MYNTRA FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE AHEAD. ONE THIRTY FOUR
YOU MAY BE ON ME PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PUBLISHED MOST. HELLO STUDENT
OF GOOD AFTERNOON- SHARE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ROBERTS
PAGERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON TOM
WYMAN SANTIAGO BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
REPRESENTING THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND SKILLED UNION
CRAFTSMEN CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AWESOME BILL PRITCHARD THE
AUTHOR'S WORK. NINE ONE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M RON MILLER
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE L.
A. ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING
TRADES. AND ON BEHALF OF THE
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND SKILLED
AND TRAINED MEN AND WOMEN OF
OUR- ORGANIZATION WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SIX ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M DAVID
COURT HIM WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
TWELVE AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. ONE NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RODRIGUEZ CHAIRMAN HI
REVISION YOU REVENGE ARAMBULA
LOCALS HUNDRED OF LOS ANGELES
HELLO WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
WHERE SOME. I B. NINETEEN THANK
YOU. NINE ONE SIX THREE. YOUR
LINE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FREDDIE
FROM TRUST IN LOW FIRE. AND I'M
GOING ON SUPPORTERS BELIEF-
WHAT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE WILL COME
UP NOW TO. OPPOSITION WILL CALL
THE LEAD OPPOSITE. WITNESS MY
RUBLE CALL ABC CENTRAL FOR- I
BELIEVE ON THE CO TOWN LINE YOU
THERE YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBER MASAK
FOR CHAPTER ONE TAKING OUT WE
AND THE WHOLE. CERTIFIED
ELECTRICIAN. AND IF YOU WERE TO
DISPLACE LOCAL WORKERS YOU'RE
GOING TO BRING A NEW WORKERS
THAT AREN'T FAMILIAR WITH THE
HAZARDS AND WOULD BE IN THE OIL
FIELDS CREATING UPDATE THE
ISSUE WHICH I THINK SENATOR
STERN HAS SAID. THE REASON FOR
THIS BILL IS TO CREATE A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT AND WE ARE
COMPLETELY ALIGNED WITH HIS.
PURPOSE OF THE BILL JUST REALLY
QUICKLY IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
WITH A CALIFORNIA PASSED
LEGISLATION REQUIRING ALL
ATTRITION WORKING UNDER THREE
TEN LICENSED CONTRACTORS TO BE
CERTIFIED. THE STATE CREATED
THREE SEPARATE PATHWAYS FOR THE
CERTIFICATION AND ALLOW THAT
JOURNEY PERSONS WHO CAN APPROVE
EIGHT THOUSAND HOURS OF
ELECTRICAL EXPERIENCE. FOR THE
STATE EXAM AND THEN FOR NON
JOURNEY KIRSTEN STATE BUDGET
REQUIRED THAT EITHER YOU ENTER
A STATEAPPROVEDAPPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM OR YOU GO TO A STATE
APPROVED- ELECTRICIAN TRAINING
PROGRAM. BOTH OF THOSE REQUIRED
EIGHT THOUSAND HOURS ON THE JOB
EXPERIENCE AND ONCE YOU DID
MEET THAT REQUIREMENT YOU WERE
ABLE TO SIT FOR THE STATE EXAM
IF YOU HAD A SUCCESSFUL PASSAGE
THEN EVERYTHING WILL INDIVIDUAL
REGARDLESS IF YOUR JOURNEY
PERCENT OR YOU WENT TO AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM OR YOU
WENT TO THE TRAINING PROGRAM.
YOU ARE A. STATE CERTIFIED
ELECTRICIAN. SIXTY ELECTRIC
CERTIFICATION. CORRECT
COMMITTEE FORM BY THE I. R. AT.
CURRICULUM STANDARD. ALL OFF
ENTITIES YOU COULD ONLY INCOME.
TRAIN AT OUTLINED IN THE EAST
IN YOUR- THE ONLY THING WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS SB ONE NINE TWO
YOU CAN. CERTIFIED- TO BE
EQUIVALENT TO SKILLED AND
TRAINED WE AGREE WITH SENATOR
STERN HAVING A SKILLED AND
TRAINED ELECTRICAL WORKFORCE IT
IS IN EVERYONE'S BENEFIT WE'RE
SAYING WE HAVE MEN AND WOMEN
CURRENTLY ON THE JOB WHO ARE
MEDIAN HIS INTENT WITH ME I'D
HAVE A CERTIFIED ELECTRICIAN
FROM BAKERSFIELD JENNY GUYER.
AND HE WOULD JUST REALLY
QUICKLY LIKE SHE DID WITH HIS.
POSITION AS WELL. JIMMY GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN. MANY IS
JAMIE. AND I AM A CERTIFIED
ELECTORS WORK IN THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY IN KERN COUNTY. MY
TITLE OF CERTIFIED ELECTRICIANS
MEANS EVERYTHING TO ME. THE
REASON I HAVE A CAREER IT
SHOULD STAINED MY FAMILY AND IT
IS MY IDENTITY AND MY COMMUNITY
OF BAKERSFIELD. I AM PROUD TO
HAVE COMPLETED THE LONG PROCESS
TO BECOME A CERTIFIED
ELECTRICIANS AND FAMILY I HAVE.
CREATED BECAUSE OF THIS CAREER
PATH. IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
CALIFORNIA CREATED A PROCESS
THAT ALL LECTURES AND THE NEXT
DAY HE HAD TO GO THROUGH IT
REQUIRED ME TO SIT THROUGH FOUR
YEARS OF CLASS AND THE STATE
APPROVED ELECTRICAL TRAINING
PROGRAM. I ATTENDED AND
GRADUATED FROM THE PROGRAM
AFFILIATED WITH A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COLLEGE OF
THE SEQUOIAS. AND THE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS. AFTER COMPLETING
THE REQUIRED EIGHT THOUSAND
HOURS OF ON THE JOB TRAINING I
PASSED THE STATE EXAM. AND
BECAME A CERTIFIED
ELECTRICIANS. WITHOUT AND
PROVIDING NEW WITH A JOB AND-
NEED TO ALL THE- TRAINING PRO.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE MY LIFE
WOULD BE. I AM HERE TODAY TO
REQUEST THAT YOU ALLOW ALL
CERTIFY ELECTOR AND BEGIN.
SKILLED AND- AFTER ALL WE ARE
ALL SORT OF ELECT AND WE ALL
PAY THIS EXAM. WE ALL HAD A
THOUSAND OUR OF ALL THE JOB
TRAINING AND WE ALL ARE REQUIRE
TO SEE THIRTY HOURS OF
CONTINUING AND. MY OFFER TO
WORK JUST BECAUSE DID NOT AND
OF COURSE. PROGRAM ALL. RIGHT
THANK YOU THAT OF THE OFFICE
WILL- WE WILL- CALL FOR ANY
WITH AND ALL HERE IN THE ROOM-
SEEN NONE- WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
ANY IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM AND WE
SEE THAT THERE ARE NONE- WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE MODERATOR
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE SP FOUR AT
NINETEEN AND LET US KNOW THE
NUMBER SPEAKERS PLEASE AGAIN
THIS IS. TESTIMONY THIS LIMITED
TO NAME TITLE AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
NINETEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT WE
HAVE ONE A THREE WE HAVE. ONE
MOMENT. WE HAVE FIVE PARTIES IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. NINE
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MY NAME
IS JOBS PAULINE I AM
REPRESENTING THE KERN INYO AND
MONO COUNTIES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL I
AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT I HAVE
BEEN ON THIS CALL TWO THIRTY
AND COULD NOT GET RECOGNIZED
UNTIL JUST NOW. AND I WANT TO
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES. WHAT SB.
FOUR NINETEEN NINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JASON KIBBEY
WITH INNOVATIVE ENGINEERING
SYSTEMS UNDERTAKING MANAGER I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO ASK
BEFORE NINETEEN. NINE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
GREG HARRIS WITH TROOPS
CORPORATION AND I'M CLOSE TO
FOUR ONE NINE UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FORTY
TWO YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO MIND.
SEVENTY EIGHT NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WONDER IF YOU WOULD
INDULGE ME SINCE MR WHICH MIS
CHARACTERIZED BY CLIENTS
POSITION. THIS IS A RETURN LINE
IS FOR- SO THIS ONE IS FOR
OPPOSITION ONLY WE CAN TAKE
YOUR NAME OR TITLE IN YOUR
OFFICE SESSION. IF THAT'S THE
CASE. NO I UNDERSTAND BUT
MISTER WHICH WHICH IS
CHARACTERIZEDMY CLIENTS ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF
I'M SORRY THE RULES SO FAR SAID
THE HEAD OF THE- COMMITTEE
MEETINGS AND THEY'RE SO EQUAL
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. IN
THE SENSE OF FAIRNESS. IN ALSO
THE FIRST AMENDMENT NOVEL BUNCH
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH SO. THANK YOU
MORTARS OR SOMEONE ELSE- QUEUED
UP AT THIS TIME. YES AND OUR
CALLER DID REMOVE HIMSELF FROM
THE COMIC YOU MIND- WE HAVE ONE
LINE LEFT TO PROVIDE THE NUMBER
ONE ON.
ONE ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MARCUS WAITER A
NUMBER OF CERTIFIED TEACHERS
AND THEY'VE BEEN IN BAKER
STREET I WILL CRY THE
INNOVATIVE VISIONARY SYSTEMS
AND I'M OPPOSED TO THE EARTH
BEFORE NINETEEN UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED- FOR THE CHANGE TO
INCLUDE. ALTERED BY CHRISTIAN.
KILLED THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR THE JOB- WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF MANBIJ SERIES SO YOU MEAN IN
DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION I DID ME PROCEED S. R.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK- I DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT WOULD GREATLY. REDUCE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BOTH ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY. AND PROSPERITY FOR
MANY EMPLOYEES. INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE COMPLETED EIGHT THOUSAND
HOURS OF WORK AND RECEIVED A
LICENSURE THROUGH THE STATE
WOULD BE EXCLUDED SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY GRADUATED FROM AN
ALTERNATIVE APPRENTICE- THIS
BILL IS CREATING A SYSTEM OF
INEQUITY I WOULD ENSURE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK IS NOT
AFFORDED TO ALL. MIND YOU N
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THESE
EMPLOYEES HAVE ALREADY PROVEN
THEIR MERIT FOR THE JOB. I JUST
CAN'T PHANTOM THE LEGISLATURE
OUR COMMITTEE STATING THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
WORTHY OF THEIR JOB BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT. GO TO SCHOOL.
HAVE AN APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
WITH A CERTAIN PROGRAM. IN MY
PERSONAL OPINION. IT IS
APPALLING. FOR THIS REASON HIGH
WILL BE NOT ABLE TO SUPPORT SB
FOUR NINETEEN. THANK YOU.
KAMALA VOTE SURE OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS CENTER NEWMAN
THANK YOU MISTER SO THERE'S
BEEN A BUNCH OF BACK AND FORTH.
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE PARTNERSHIP AND I THINK THE
CERTIFIED ELECTRICIANS SO WITH
FOR MY EDIFICATION ASSUME
OTHERS IF WE COULD HAVE MISTER
WHICH COME BACK AND CLARIFY IF
POSSIBLE TO. THANK YOU SO GOT
WHICH ABOUT SISTER STATION
ELECTRICAL WORKERS- TRAINEE
PROGRAMS WERE AUTHORIZED. AS A
PATHWAY FOR PEOPLE WHO HAD
WORKED IN THE LEXICAL FIELD AB
WERE OLDER AND HAD GOTTEN THE
EIGHT THOUSAND HOURS OF WORK IN
THE FIELD BUT HAD NOT GONE
THROUGH OFFICIAL TRAINING
PROGRAM THEY COULD SIT AND TAKE
THE TEST- THOSE STANFORD. A
CERTIFICATION LAW
DIFFERENTIATES BETWEEN TRAINEES
AND APPRENTICES IN SEVERAL
SIGNIFICANT WAYS ONE BEING. AN
APPRENTICE IN A PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. ONE JOURNEYMEN
CONSUMER VICE TO APPRENTICES
BECAUSE THEY ARE VIEWED AS
BEING A HIGHER SKILLED TRAINEE
WHEREAS. A TRAINEE HAS TO BE
SUPERVISED ON A ONE TO ONE
BASIS BY ADJOURNMENT BECAUSE
ARE NOT OF THE SAME LEVEL LET
ME GIVE YOU AN ANALOGY. YOU CAN
SIT FOR THE BAR OF CALIFORNIA
YOU CAN READ AND STUDY AND SIT
AND TAKE THE BAR. TO BECOME. A
LAWYER. LIKE KIM KARDASHIAN IS
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU WANT KIM
KARDASHIAN REPRESENTING YOU IN
COMPLEX LITIGATION OKAY THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
YES. THE STATE CERTIFICATION IS
THE FLOOR IT'S NOT THE CEILING
OKAY IT'S THE MINIMUM NOT THE
PREFERRED LEVEL OF TRAINING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. BUT
YOU MAY ALSO NEW NOW AND I'D BE
GLAD TO MOVE THE BILL
INAPPROPRIATE. OKAY ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ISSUE SENATOR BYRD I
WAS JUST GOING TO. ASK THE SAME
THING THAT. ARE SENATOR NEWMAN
DID BECAUSE THERE WERE A LOT OF
COMMUNICATIONS FROM PEOPLE THIS
WEEKEND WITH EXACTLY THAT POINT
AND I THINK IT GOT ANSWERED. I
IT MORE NATURAL RESOURCES WE
HEARD THIS BILL ALREADY WE HAD
AN ANIMATED DISCUSSION SO I
FEEL ARE COMFORTABLE WITH IT I
JUST. GRABBED HERE ABOUT THAT
ONE ISSUE. THE NEW THE LIKEWISE
GIVEN- MY POSITION HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE WE FROM HER HEARD A
LOT ABOUT- ALL SIDES HERE-
HOPEFULLY IF THERE'S ANY ANY
FURTHER. ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT- THE AUTHOR. OF WILL
NAVIGATOR TO GET THOSE DONE- WE
HAVE SOMEONE PREPARED MAKE
MOTION- SENATOR STERN- BUT YOU
ARE ENTITLED TO CLOSE SENSIBLE
FOR DO THAT UP TO THIS TIME. X.
MISTER CHAIR THERE WAS A GOOD
DIALOGUE AND CLARIFYING IN SOME
RESPECTS AND JUST WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WE'LL- KEEP WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE COMMUNITIES WE GO
FOR. WE APPRECIATE THE TERM
SENATE NEWMAN- WILL COME WILL
COUNT YOUR COMMON AS A MOTION
THEN LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU MISTER ALL RIGHT MISS
FOR IF WE CAN- CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CORTEZ AND HI AND A
CORTES III SENATOR JOE BOOK NOW
SENATOR JOE FOLK NO SENATOR
TORONTO. SENATOR LAYERED BY
EARLIER HI SENATOR NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT- NEWMAN AYE. THOUGH THE
TO IS THREE. TWO THREE THE
THREE ICE ONE OPPOSE IN ONE
ABSENT- SO WE'LL LEAVE THE BILL
ON COAL THE BILL ON CALL OF
HERE AND- WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL MOMENTARILY- I KNOW
THAT SENATOR DRAWS SO- I
BELIEVE IS- SOMEWHERE IN THE
VICINITY MAYBE YOU CAN ASK A-
THE SERGEANTS TO ASSIST US IN.
LOCATING OVER IF YOU HAD A FIVE
MINUTE SPEECH AND SHE LEFT
ABOUT TEN MINUTES AGO SO
HOPEFULLY SHE'S GIVING IT. HE
SHOULD BE BACK HERE SHORTLY
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
CENTER WHERE. THE OTHERWISE
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA OTHER THAN.
OTHER THAN A TWO THERE'S TWO
BILLS THAT I BELIEVE- WE HAVE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON- LET ME. THE
LAW IS LIGHT AS WELL WITH THE
CALL ON. TWO THIRTY TWO SB TWO
THIRTY TWO- LEGAL IN CALI
ABSENT MEMBER ON THAT. MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ
ALL RIGHT ANACORTES THE I.
THANK YOU. IN ONE SENATOR DRAWS
GETS HERE. FIT THAT BILL SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY TWO- DID HAVE A
FIVE TWO ZERO VOTE OVER ALSO
THE BILL IS OUT LET ME SEE
STATE THAT FOR THE RECORD.
THANKS TO THE BILL TO SEVENTY
IS THE OTHER BILL THAT- IS THAT
CORRECT. HI I'M A WEEK BEHIND.
GERMAN REPEALING. SENATE BILL
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE PER TO LESS
YOU. BECAUSE OF LOTUS. SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE. HE PROBABLY CAN
LEAVE THE ROOM. THANK YOU. THAT
WAS MY SISTER'S PIECE SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE IS NOT THE.
APOLOGIZE FOR THE BLUES IN AN
OUT TODAY BECAUSE OF SOME
URGENT. ISSUES ASIDE TO TAKE
CARE OF UNEXPECTED LISA HOPE.
HI I'M TRYING TO PLAY CATCH UP
HERE ON- BUT HAT WE NEED TO DO
TO CLOSE OF THE MEETING THANK
YOU AGAIN MENTAL BY SURE FOR
ALL YOUR HELP TODAY. IN.
THANKLESS JOB THEIR JOB. THANK
YOU.
C. THIS THANK WE ARE ONE
OF THE CALL ON- IN THIS PIECE
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE ILLNESS BEFORE
NINETEEN IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN IS
THAT CORRECT YES. NOT THOSE
FIRST IS TO SENATE BILL SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR PER ALSO ALL RIGHT
THUNDER TORONTO OCT. IN THE I
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL IS NOW
OUT ON A FIVE TWO ZERO VOTERS
ARE CORRECT IN THEM. HI THAT IS
CONFIRMED THE BILLS OUT ON THE
FIVE ZERO VOTES WILL COME BACK
NOW TO SENATE BILL FOUR
NINETEEN. AND WILL SHE TO WITH
THE CALL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR ALSO HI SENATOR ALSO
ALL. RIGHT THE BILL PASSES OF
FORTY ONE IN THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU OF IT AT THIS POINT
FROM OUR COMMITTEE MEETING THIS
COMPLETE AND THE MEAT IS
INSURANCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU